want to get started
hours
there
was
is I'm gonna ask committee members to
seats
good morning everyone welcome to
environment and agriculture I know we're
waiting for uh one or two people still
and um pardon our appearance as we
remodel uh I understand there was a leak
in the ceiling here and uh and there's
still working on uh the repairs so uh
about I am going to um start first of
all welcome to environment and
agriculture everybody and
um I want to thank uh representative
rung representative uh Ren Zulo and
representative Vose for sitting in this
morning as
substitutes uh during our exec session
Welcome to our committee and thank you
so much for your volunteering to
substitute we appreciate your time I
want to start by um having uh
representative Davis lead us in the uh
Allegiance Al to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
indivisible liy and justice for
you so this morning on our docket we uh
we have four bills that we are uh going
to be executing I'm going to do them in
reverse order uh if nobody Minds so we
will start out with HB
155 uh which is establishing an animal
abuse offender registry I open the exec
session on that
and um do I hear a motion Madam chair uh
representative ktoa Madam chair I I make
a motion to itl please do I hear a
second representative Bixby I'll second
that uh representative ktoa would you
like to speak to your motion yes Madam
chair so this bill although
well-intentioned
really does not accomplish the goal of
because they they want a registry but
yet we know it's two to three years out
before there's any possible legal suit
and what they're trying to do is get
information prior to that and so this
bill would not accomplish their
goals is there any discussion other
discussion regarding
hp55 uh representative Bixby yeah I one
of my concerns with this bill is that um
it there are a number of due process
issues that it brings up that are not uh
that are not resolved in the bill and I
think that um this uh if the idea is to
create better communication between law
enforcement agencies this a bill that's
concerned considered by this committee
is not uh actually the right place to be
doing that it it should be something
that should be considered by people in
in criminal justice and safety who have
more expertise in dealing in how law
enforcement
works thank you representative Bixby any
representative gerana thank you madam
chair yes I I want to say I I spoke in
the elevator after our hearing with the
animal uh control officer uh who was
here and and expressed some things that
are similar to what representative Bixby
was just saying uh she was kind of
asking how in the future might be better
uh and and we were talking about the
idea that there could be
a database that uh is for the use not
open to the public but is for the use of
law enforcement and the idea that
possibly um certified or licensed
shelters could perhaps for a fee or
whatever have access if they're talking
about adopting out for example but so uh
I agree that it is a good idea but not
uh as it would be executed in that bill
so I support the itl thank you anyone
else represent Sak
for all the years that um I've been here
this comes up frequently and I think
it's um it could be subjective so I've
had people call the dog officer on me
for dog for animal cruelty because my
new Finland dogs were outside in the
snow and I would think that they would
call them in July when it's so hot I
have to bribe my dogs in the winter to
come in you know so I think it's a hard
thing because people think that they're
doing good and they want to protect but
I just think it's it's very subjective
this animal
cruelty thank you representative sopus
anybody else seeing none I would ask the
clerk to call the role on this thank you
madam chair uh the motion is itl on HB
155 representative kraton I
representative coma yes representative
Rulo
yes representative Davis yes
representative Vose yes representative
kulan yes representative Kenny yes
represent uh smart yes representa Bixby
yeah yes representative sakas yes
representative rang yes representative
Murray yes representative Jama yes
represent H Haskins I represent Howard
yes represent NAB yes represent mois yes
representa ban yes madame chair yes 190
shall this go on
consent I should say it does any anybody
against no good that'll be on consent
then thank you so much
um and I'll close out the exec for uh
hp55 and I will open up the exec for HB
1325 which is relative to allowing
private owner ownership of small-tailed
monkeys raccoons foxes otter skunks and
kangaroos do I hear a motion
representative Bixby I move
itl do I hear a
second representative Craton second yes
ma'am I second okay um do you want to
speak to your motion representative
Bixby yes um
the
uh what we heard uh in testimony uh
was uh was that
uh kind that these animals really are
not uh appropriate for uh home pet own
ownership they are essentially wild
animals and uh they they don't have the
domestication in their bread into them
that is necessary to make them viable as
uh pets uh for people people who are not
really trained and uh have sufficient
background we already have a procedure
in uh our fishing game laws that allows
the ownership of these animals for
people who uh show to the fishing game
that they have a capability of taking
care of them properly uh so I think that
uh opening opening ownership of these up
to uh people who just want want them
because it's a cool idea could end up
having our shelters dealing with
Kangaroos and short-tail monkeys that
people decide they can't handle after a
short while and we don't want to put
that burden on our shelters
representative compa thank you madam
chair I think part of the most
concerning part of this bill was they
would be all designated as companion
animals which means that in a disaster
they would have to be housed um and also
they would be uh subject to the same
laws as companion animals for uh a
domesticated animals so that really is
concerning thank you madam chair
representive
sakias did they happen to say how many
are there any of these
animals um here like kangaroos do we
have kangaroos in New Hampshire or is it
just something an
aspiration I I have have no IDE answer I
belong to quilt and guilds all over the
world because of YouTube and um so they
show these kangaroos from Australia and
they little little shits I mean they
beat up excuse me you know I I can't
imagine them being a companion animal
and in Australia they use them for for
animal food but I mean they they can
beat the crap out of somebody they're
not just like um
a little thing that you can go to the
movie with well I I I I can appreciate
that represent saitis because I I have a
a friend of mine in who lives in my town
who uh stayed at a was stationed at a a
base in um somewhere in Malaysia um and
they had a pet short-tailed monkey he
told me that they are perpetually
vicious and angry and petulant
2-year-olds that's how they behave
and there's no reasoning with them
there's no training them and they can be
pretty awful so anyway U representative
ger thank you madam chair I think we all
Remember The Bugs Bunny with the boxing
kangaroo but I did want to just to share
with with my committee colleagues and
everyone else too this morning on NPR
there was a fitting story in Australia
they have a contest every year for
dancing your PhD thesis so it's a
performance dance for your PhD thesis
and the guy who won it was on behavior
of kangaroos so uh if anyone is is
interested enough I'm sure you could
probably find that video of the guy
performing his PhD thesis on kangaroo
behavior all right any other comment on
this bill seeing none um I would like
the the clerk to call the role thank you
madam chair the motion is I on HB
1325 representative kraton hi
representative coma yes representative
Rulo yes representative Davis yes
representative V yes representative
kulan yes representative Kenny
yes representative
smart represent
Bixby yes represent sopus yes
representative rung yes representative
Murray yes representative Jam yes
representative H Haskins I
representative Howard yes representative
NAB yes representative moris yes
represent
biman yes Madam chair yes 19 Z shall It
Go on
consent
yes okay I'm going to close the exact on
hb1
1325 and I'm going to open the exact on
HB 1351 prohibiting the sale and use of
adhesive based rodent traps and I am
going to uh move itl on this
represent represent Katon representative
kraton seconds and I'll speak on my
motion
here um now we know that um any means of
eliminating rats and mice is going to
result in the end of life of the
rodent and um you know not all methods
were are going to offer a quick death
even snap traps can cause
slow uh slow deaths of these uh rodents
to
occur but I I feel that um this is a
nonchemical based means of
eliminating uh the rodent
population and I really hesitate to uh
take away that option especially since
this kind of option is used in places
where chemical baits um and
pesticides is is something that uh
shouldn't be used uh whether it be
around in Food Services um any place
that um food is grown or food is is
held uh I just think that uh to to
elimination uh a trap uh is not really a
prudent thing and um you know they use
them in commercial kitchens and uh
hospitals schools and other places where
these chemicals are inappropriate and
not safe so um that's why I am um
against this kind of
banning representative Bixby yeah so
um we also heard testimony about um a
couple of aspects one is uh the the
cruelty of the of this way of dying for
the Target animals and although the
instructions on the label do say that
the animals should be euthanased
properly there's no instructions on how
that would H how one would do that uh so
so it seems like that is a a gap in
terms of the uh the education that would
be necessary for U nonprofessionals to
appropriately use uh use these traps uh
the other uh another issue that was
brought up was that the bill as written
could cause uh a certain amount of uh
uncertainty uh in terms
of uh whether it you how uh glue traps
for insects would fall under this uh uh
uh would would be affected by this bill
and uh glue traps for insects are a are
an important part of in uh uh of um
integrated pest control because you use
those glue traps in order to uh figure
out what the what the current population
of of pests of insect pests uh is that
you would need to uh to to provide the
threshold hold for further treatment uh
and but a a third element uh that we we
heard of testimony on was
the the problems with bycatch from traps
that had been inappropriately placed in
places where uh Wildlife uh or pets
could get into them uh so uh I'm
wondering if there is something that can
be done to uh improve the way that these
traps are used used uh and I'm I think
that perhaps an interim study might be a
more appropriate
motion representative K thank you madam
chair um from an agricultural
standpoint um we need all options at our
disposal to help with the rodent problem
as we discussed in
committee
these the rodents have a two-year life
cycle and if you take off 6 months of
that they can breed 25
times over 18 months with an average
litter of
six multiply that
exponentially they are a public health
issue they create
disease they create problems in
agriculture with our grains with the
food supply for our
animals
we need
options we don't always want to use the
bait or the poisons because we don't
want our animals getting to these
rodents that have died from poisons and
sources they are
vital to places to put them in a farm
stand out of the way
to help keep them from eating the foods
that are
there they are vital in our homes when
as part of a
solution they're not the you know
they're we need options and we need all
options on the table to
utilize um to help with this problem so
I am supporting
itl uh representative H Haskins thank
you madam chair respectfully I'm going
to vote against the
itl it seems to me that it's
2024 and we have other options I did
survey a few of the um stores in my area
on the SE
Co um hardware stores lumber store and
they have the snap traps they have um
the electronic ones which I think is a
21st century uh device ice I think we
can do better than this I do think that
the insect strips um should be exempt
from this we're talking about rodents
not insects so again I can't bring
myself to vote for the itl and um I
think we can do better thank you okay
representative
gerana thank you madam chair uh I agree
with representative H Haskins that from
what we heard it seems apparent to me
that there are other less inhumane
methods of of disposing of of rodents
dealing with rodent uh infestations
which I think we all agree is is
something that we need to do uh so I
think there are other less inhumane uh
tactics and I also think that there are
plenty of other tactics that don't have
the same potential for negative impact
on other animals that are not supposed
to be uh I you know um targeted we could
do more work on this bill as has been
suggested Ed if if we wanted to to kind
of clarify for example the difference
between rodent traps and insect traps
and so for that reason I would support
representative bixby's suggestion uh of
interim study and finally this is I have
to say uh an issue on which I received a
lot of emails from constituents from
actual constituents from folks in my
district in Kean who were very
passionate um about the inhumanity
involved in this method of dealing with
rodents so uh especially to serve the
interest of my constituents I'll also be
itl representative uh
Howard thank you madam chair um I was
somewhat moved by the um the testimony
of the um of the professional in the um
in his use of them and I'm wondering if
there's a way to limit it to that
because I feel that they handle them
respons more responsibly or not
necessarily more responsibly but more um
likely to be responsible in the
collection and and humane disposal of
these things but on on the other hand I
wonder how um how uh is it possible is
it isn't it going to be difficult to um
what's the word uh to to patrol this you
know to to actually make it possible to
to stop the the sale of these
things represent NAB thank you madam
chair um I also wanted to say that I'm
planning to oppose the itl and i would
support a motion of interim study um and
part of that is because of the testimony
handed out to us that day that shows
that the CDC the New Hampshire Fish and
Game department the US fish and wildlife
service the avma the Canadian Veterinary
Medical Association all these
organizations oppose the use of glue
traps and um to me that's a compelling
argument to not use them but um I
noticed in the farm bureau's uh written
testimony they also mentioned doing an
interim study and getting some input
from the pesticide control board so for
that reason I'd be willing to support a
motion of interm study
thank you representative kraton thank
you madam chair yeah so last year we
listened to the renis side bill and the
testimony from that was that to to
amplify what representative Kon said
that 1,200 rats can be offsprings from
just a male and a female in one house
and then uh we had the pest control guys
come in and say Hey you know the if you
get rid of R genocides then you'll have
mouse droppings and baby carriages and
on in in h beds and all that kind of
stuff and so this is the second Bild
we've seen in two years to pull back on
the ability to control pest in in homes
in farms and and other places and uh
many of the other traps I I use a five
gallon bucket that has a trapo on it
that's very effective but then that's
depending on how often you check it how
how they die and there that you know
that could be perceived as that as well
you know you don't you know what are you
going to do with those mice you're going
to kill them or you going to let them go
in the woods what are you goingon to do
with them but at the end of the day it
eliminates that health risk um from from
my house so I I'm suppor of I on this
because I think that from a health
perspective and from a safety of food
perspective uh we need to have those
methods available uh to get rid of V
rodents over any other
comments seeing none I request the clerk
to call The rooll Madam chair the motion
is itl on HB 1351 representative kraton
I representative coma yes representative
Rulo yes representative Davis yes
representative Vose yes representative
kulan yes representative
Kenny representative
smart representative Bix
no Representative
sopus no representative rang no
representative Murray no representative
Jama no representative H Haskins nay
representative Howard no representative
NAB no Representative moris no
representative H Haskins M chair I move
bill uh representative German
seconds representative Bixby would you
like to speak to your
motion I believe that isor represent
Askin that's quite all right sorry no
problem um well I think the arguments
have been outlined that we would like to
look at what are the 21st century
options I think we all have the goal of
being the most
Humane uh method of getting rid of pests
that do the harm that has been stated
but I really think there are other
options and we need a little more data
about how available those options are
where they can and can't be used and I'd
be happy to be part of that okay any
other representative ger thank you madam
chair uh and I wanted to speak also to a
good point that representative Katon
brought up before which is thinking back
to when we when we looked at the redenti
side Bill last year and I know I for one
when I first came into that bill was my
initial reaction was to be in in favor
of that bill but we heard some really
compelling testimony uh from the the
pest control specialist and and from
some other folks who testified and came
around to the conclusion that that bill
as it was written was not appropriate
that it didn't give people a tool that
they needed to be able to control um
possibility of rat infestations rodent
infestations uh and so you know we
didn't end up passing that bill so I
hear what representative kraton is
saying about you know we see these bills
come back in that case we heard the
testimony and a lot of us ended up
agreeing that that bill was in the end
taking a necessary tool out of the hands
of of people who need it uh this is a
case where I think with some more study
to differentiate between different kinds
of glue traps and also to think about
how this fits into the larger Arsenal
that uh folks have at their disposal for
dealing with rodents I think interim
study is an appropriate motion so thank
you representative Bixby I'd also like
to point out that on that rodenticide
bill we moved that interim study and did
have input from the pesti pesticide
control board uh before we um uh before
we disposed of it in the fall as being
as recommending um oh actually we we
moved it uh retained that and then we we
did inter we did the um itl in the fall
after we had gotten information from the
pesticide control board and I'd actually
like to get some updates from them about
what the current federal status is
because there was part of the reason
that we
uh eventually it that was because of
potential Federal Federal legislation
that would affect it but but on the top
on this topic I think that uh we can it
makes sense to do a study to um to
figure out what options there are for um
for making sure that the traps are
handled better okay any other comment on
this seeing none I uh would like the
clerk to call the role thank you Madam
chair the motion is interim study on HB
1351 representative kraton I
representative coma no representative
Ren Zulo I representative Davis yes
representative
Vose yes represent kulan no
Kenny representative smart
no representative
Bixby yes representative sopus yes
representative rung yes represent Murray
yes represent Jam yes represent H
Haskins I represent Howard yes
representative NAB yes representative
Morris yes represent ban yes Madam
chair
yes
okay motion passes um who is who would
write The Minority Report I will okay
and um you get the you get you moved it
you get the
report I'd be happy to help you thank
you okay I'm going to close out the exec
for HB
1351 and open up um the exact for HB
1221 relative to including Solid Waste
landfills and the definition of
development of regional
impact um now as I understand there was
an amendment that was forthcoming for
this and
um it is not come to us yet so um I
would be looking to um move this uh exec
session to next week and also have
representative ger give us an update on
uh what was happening with this
Bill thank you madam chair uh and I
appreciate the willingness of the chair
and the committee to exec this next week
I've been working with the prime sponsor
to amend a couple of of parts of the
bill that we talked about uh for example
one the distance that we we would be
talking about originally I believe the
bill was at 20 miles we're looking at
changing that to 10 miles uh and then
also the um trying to make sure that
when we're talking about water sheds we
have the right maps that we're
referencing uh and so we have that
information we submitted it to ol
unfortunately the amendment we received
back yesterday was missing some of that
Vital Information so uh we are
continuing to work with them we should
have it very very soon so the committee
will have a week to look at the amended
uh the proposed amendment thank you okay
thank you um so I am going to um
postpone this or I guess I don't
remember the correct wording for it I
guess uh to recess this thank you recess
the exac for um for this bill hb1
1221 uh for next week uh when we exec
our bills at 10:00 Wednesday March
13th and uh so I'm going to uh recess
this exec until then and there we go end
it um and so we are not uh scheduled
until 10:45 live so we have 15 minutes
uh where we will then begin a full
committee work session on uh five
different bills that we have heard
already so let's take a break and I'll
see you in
minutes
like committee members to please take
their
seats we we are going to be getting
agenda
okay um we we're waiting for
uh yep we're going to get started
started on um I'm going to open up our
full committee work session and the
first bill that we are going to discuss
and we're we have until noon today uh to
go through these five bills and just see
them so the first bill that we want to
discuss is HB 1316 relative to
co-ownership of dogs
and we heard some testimony about that
last
week I will tell you that my own
thoughts on this bill is that
um
um I don't I don't know that we need to
change anything stat statutorily
regarding this it it seemed to me that
what we were we were having to um look
at is really a local zoning issue that's
been a problem
um and I I'm not so sure that um
further defining co-ownership of dogs in
our statutes would really make any kind
of difference
um I don't know what any other thoughts
on
that representative Howard I agree Madam
chair and um I think that uh the
enforcement of zoning is difficult but
it does fall in the perview of the city
the city or the town rather than um here
at the state level yeah because it would
seem to me that if if this um person is
is running a Doggy Daycare of some sort
that that's a business that would have
to be um declared with the Secretary of
State's office and there's a whole whole
protocol that goes along with that it's
not just that uh you know someone is
deciding to quote unquote watch a
friend's dog for the afternoon um this
person is running a business and there
are local zoning ordinances regarding
these businesses so um yeah I I'm I'm
not real keen on making any kind of uh
changes representative Bixby yeah so um
I see a couple of issues one is that uh
there is a
practical uh there there's a there's an
existing practice in terms of
co-ownership of dogs that is in the uh
in the show dog world uh and that is
done entirely through contract law right
and that's probably where it really
belongs uh the other thing is that uh
the description of the problem we heard
in Manchester was really an issue of
fraud uh that exactly the uh that people
who wanted their dogs taken care of by
this particular person would uh have
that uh caretaker added to the dog's
registration and this seems like uh
something that would probably be more in
the Attorney General's ballpark than
ours exactly any other comments on this
bill represent
STIs um I'm not sure if you all know how
much money is tied up in showd dogs but
um what you're paying for in showd dogs
is you're paying for their the lineage
so um there's I have newand dogs and
when you buy them from a a reputable
breeder that has a huge show thing you
end up paying that money that she's put
into her line and um the line that I
have um actually just got she pulled in
another dog from um Poland so that she
could keep her line fresh and good and
so I know we're going to hear a bill
this afternoon about the dogs with and
cats with mushed in faces but that is a
problem of poor breeding and
so co-ownership of dogs in the in the um
I would say that some of these dogs are
20 and
$30,000 it's a significant amount of
level any other discussion about this
bill
concerns okay well yeah I mean I I I I
do see that um with this bill um the
problem that it's trying to solve really
is an issue of fraud it's an issue of um
local zoning um and I I don't know that
um making any kind of change to um to
co-ownership in our statute is going to
change anything um with having to do
with the issue that's being dealt or
being um dealt with in Manchester
so um with that I guess we have no other
conversation on uh HB
1316 and so um move on to HB 1173
relative to the disposition of vicious
dogs anybody have any idea um thoughts
bill represent muray thank you madam
chair if if just so I'm sure that we're
we're talking about the requirement for
uh muzzling is that
correct no no this is a bill that
provides for the euthanizing of dogs
that attack humans than I apologize or
domestic animals and um I mean as far as
I'm concerned we already have we already
have legis statute that deals with dogs
that are vicious and that cause
damage
um so represent Bixby yeah and uh the
existing statutes that deal with uh dogs
that are problematic uh you know vicious
or uh or or causing other problems does
allow uh local law enforcement and uh
the courts to impose restrictions on
animals that are being uh that are um
deemed vicious and that and those
measures could uh on multiple uh after
multiple fences include uh euthanasia
but uh making it
required H does not leave enough human
discretion in the process and there
there needs to be human discretion in
order to for instance one one issue that
was brought up was what if the dog that
you have two dogs one is a that get into
a fight one is uh a dog that initiates
the problem and uh by harassing this the
second dog the second dog responds by
defending itself and causing a bite to
the to the uh dog that started the
problem uh that see but the dog that
would Su that would be under this
proposed under this bill the dog that
responded is the one that would be
subject to being euthanased uh if a dog
is on its own property guarding sheep
and some someone
trespasses if that happens twice and
that dog bites a
trespasser that dog would be euthanased
under this bill MH that is not
appropriate right and there needs to the
current law that has the ability for the
law enforcement and the judge to use
discretion is uh is the way it should be
which is RSA 466 colon 28 I
believe thank you representative
gerana thank you madam chair and I agree
with much of what represented Bixby uh
just said and it's just for the
committee and I could send it around if
anyone wants to see it Michigan State
University their animal legal and
Historical Center has a list of all of
the states who have dangerous dog laws
uh including Youth and Asia laws and
then most of them are as representative
Bixby was describing uh discretionary so
that there's a panel or that there's an
official and evidence is weighed a few
states do appear to have mandatory but
those appear to involve really vicious
attacks we're not talking about a bite
that breaks the skin we're talking about
a significant you know mauling a really
tragic event so um and I can if any I
can send that link around if anyone
wants to see it because I think it's a
good comparison with other states but I
agree it's something that should be left
up to officials or panels or some level
of human discretion so thank you agree
with
that anyone else have any comments on
this
bill okay seeing none we can move along
then um
h501
repealing the requirement to register
dogs
annually um there's been a lot of emails
flying back and forth um regarding this
bill because I know representative
Hobson wanted was was
contemplating um submitting an amendment
to this
bill which would um get rid of the
entire bill but address a problem
problem having to do with um
notification if somebody is delinquent
in in obtaining a dog license then uh
the town clerk has to send them some
sort of notification in the mail
certified mail and in statute right now
there's a specific dollar amount that um
they specify should be spent or is
allowed to be spent and uh postage is
gone up since the statute was enacted so
she wanted to put an amendment that
would change that to allow
for um proper postage to be um uh you
know take so that the town doesn't have
to pay that uh difference in postage
that the postage is then uh paid for by
the uh person who the mail is being sent
to anyway there so there's been some
discussion about um put putting an
amendment on this
bill um but the underlying Bill itself I
think uh repealing the dog
licensing uh is not something that I
would be in favor of simply because of
you know we do tie this
into um getting rabies vaccinations and
and that's important that everybody does
that anybody have any other comments
about it representative
Bixby so um I think that the underlying
bill in terms of repealing the uh the
the license or changing the license uh
frequency to for instance B anual which
was a I believe a uh an amendment that
had been proposed at some point I I
think is inappropriate I think that uh I
think that one of the over the years
we've had various bills that try to uh
amend the LIC cycle and we've had
testimony from the state veterinarian
that we do not want to mess around with
um the insurance of Li of of vaccination
that the licensing Pro um P the
licensing system gives us uh rabies
is when uh is is almost universally
deadly in humans uh if it is not caught
uh before symptoms begin to exhibit and
I believe that um back several years ago
Dr Crawford said there there was only
one known um person who surviv who lived
after Contracting rabies and that that
person probably wished they were dead
and so uh rabies is not something we
want to mess around with the current
system works very well uh I don't think
that it makes any sense to try and
change it
uh in terms of the cost of $7 per year
for a license fee that is substantially
lower than many of our neighboring
states uh and if you can't afford $7 a
year for a license fee you don't you
were not in a position to take care of a
dog I mean that is less than a week's
worth of
food so and you know I also wanted to
point out um we we had some testimony
come in from uh Jay finy who used to
chair this committee um and he had been
talking about this bill with the aworth
town
clerk um and and she felt that licensing
serves a very valuable service when it
comes to animal control and definitely
has been a valuable tool for recovering
a lost
dog um so rabies tag and a dog tag
they're not the same in fact where a dog
has been licensed should it bite someone
license will determine quickly whether
or not that stray dog has been
vaccinated for rabies so there's there
really is a reason for these tags the
rabies tags that the dogs
wear um representative Morris you had
something you wanted to say about this
apologies for stepping out no worries I
I I think we're all on the same page
here I think that it's it's so important
that we make sure the dogs are are
registered and that we you know are of
um what dogs have been vaccinated and so
um I think kind of coming to a
conclusion after hearing everyone else
it sounds like we're all sort of on the
same page I'm open to the possibility of
of you know um discussing mailing out
reminders for people or or that sort of
thing but I think uh at the the end of
the day um continuing to register dogs
on a yearly basis for well and even the
amendment um I know representative Hull
had sent an amendment that would change
this to be a
banial um
registration and I know what we had
heard a bill in the past about that and
the town clerks came out and said that
would be terrible for them to manage
because they can't it's easy if
everybody has to register every year but
if you have to register every other year
and you're off cycle of when they're
going to be getting their rabies shots
then it makes it even more confusing um
but if there's a lapse and and aemp
clerk has to keep track of oh these dogs
are uh coming up for Renewal this year
and these dogs are coming up the next
year or the year after it becomes too
much of a um administrative um yeah and
I nightmare to do that our town clerks
are already working hard enough so
representative
NAB oh I'm sorry that it was Murray's
hand it was up I'm sorry that's okay
thank you madam chair um so yes I agree
um as far as with regards to the town
clerk's role and and um the ability to
notify folks that their registration is
up for Renewal while they also send uh
paper not notice they they many Town
clerks also send electronic notification
that renewal is up therefore like saving
costs of of postage in some ways um
right so I to to just piggyback off of
Representative mors I think we're widely
in agreement
here okay represent VI Bixby okay so in
term in terms of the proposed amendment
from representative Hobson to uh to
raise the ra mailing reimbursement that
is not for the regular notification that
is for notification if someone is
delinquent and they need to be um given
a they need to be sent certified mail to
make sure that they are uh that they
know that they uh should come in and
register their animal uh and I agree
that that that those costs should be
those that reimbursement rate should be
raised to match what is uh currently
appropriate but I don't think this is
the bill to do that uh there is a bill
that we passed um uh without in in
barely the wink of an eye uh to um in to
change where the dedicated where the
which dedicated M money some of the dog
license um which dedicated fund some of
the dog license money goes to uh that
and that that has gone to house finance
uh or ways and mean no Ians means where
it may have already passed there but
that's that is going to be quickly
passed by Ways and Means because it was
a bill that they bipartisanly SP you
know proposed right and that's going to
go over to the Senate there's another
issue in terms of making sure that uh
reimbursement is um being done correctly
which is that um the current span neuter
uh reimbursement for veterinarians is
not keeping up and we're losing
veterinarians who are willing to
participate in that program uh the
Senate and uh and the commissioner have
agreed to do an amendment on that I
think that bill would be a very good
place to also do an amendment to this
notific the dog license not this
notification uh mailing cost so I think
it would be better for us to L this bill
and recommend to the Senate that uh they
um include the issue of the mail the
certified mail to um to the to that bill
that we've already
passed yes and I've uh I've suggested
that to representative Hobson and she's
open to that as well so I mean she's
just looking for a bill that she can get
that Amendment passed to help out uh
help solve that problem in not only her
town but all across the state so um I
will then be sending that recommendation
to representative Hobson that um she
speak to either Senator Pearl or Senator
avard and make sure that that Amendment
gets attached in the Senate any other
questions or comments regarding this
particular
bill I mean otherwise I don't I don't
see that it's prudent at all for us to
either
repeal uh dog licensing Reg registration
annually or even make it banial or
trianal so um any other comments to that
effect seeing none I think we'll move on
to um relative to exemptions from the
1556 uh anybody have any questions or
comments about
that I did send out an email to you all
um with some uh feedback from from our
state veterinarian Dr Crawford on the
issue of uh
exemptions and um I don't know I hope
that you've all received it and that you
read
it I think he makes some very Salient
points um regarding
that so I mean I I get it that um you
know if you have an older animal that's
sick um and is not able to be vaccinated
that some of the quarantine protocol
might be difficult but um there is
latitude in the statute that um a person
can work with their local animal control
officer
to
um maybe mitigate some of the issues
that uh you have when you have a a dog
in that
situation representative
kraton yes ma'am I guess where I fall on
this is we got a a system where rabies
is not a problem in this state it's not
a problem because we pass certain laws
that prevent it from happening why would
we screw with that so I'm on it on this
okay represent suffi is just as a nurse
I'm just going to throw this out there
that um all animals from the tiniest
little animal to a big horse they all
get the same dose and um that one was a
hard one for me being because in in um
human health care a lot of these drugs
are weight specific and so for me that I
have 200 PB dogs to think that a little
Chihuahua is going to get the same
dosage that my huge dogs are it just it
sort of doesn't fly scientifically for
me and um rabies titer are something
that I'm sure that we're going to hear
more I had submitted a bill years ago um
and it never never got anywhere but the
same people are um in Kansas University
they're the ones that are doing the all
the research on rabies titer and what it
means and
um one of my dog whisperers um St
Bernard
dogs has an autoimmune disease and they
had a titer done on his dog on her dog
and um showed that he was
he had enough of the arabes um vaccine
in him to last for seven years so it's a
funny thing but I think that the science
is something to keep an eye on the
science is going to come around to to
this absolutely and I I remember the
discussions we had about um exemptions
uh circling around the uh rabies vaccine
titer and that the issue was that there
was the tests were not standard enough
enough that if you sent blood work to
one lab and blood work to another lab
there was possible you could get two
different results and so until the time
that they get the rabies tighter um
testing standardized and really accurate
uh I don't think that we're going to see
any kind of exemptions um you know from
that but in dealing with this particular
issue uh you have an older sicker dog or
something like that to give any other
further exemption than we already give
um is uh could be problematic I think
and and dangerous represent Bixby yeah
so um I think the uh yeah um I I'm I
think that what Dr Crawford said about
this being a um this being this Le this
statute being good as it currently
stands is um is really important I think
that the fact that there is that ability
for a dog owner to work individually
with the with local animal control is
critical but I think that is also uh as
representative kraton pointed out the
reason that we don't have a ra rabies
problem in New Hampshire and in fact in
in our entire country is because we have
very good vaccination programs for our
domestic animals and uh the the
countries that don't have this the qu
the level of vaccination that for rabies
that we
do do have problems with people dying of
rabies there are very very few deaths
from rabies in the United States or
Canada uh because we they these
countries have excellent vaccination
rates
um just one of one of the things about
the biology of the vaccine uh vaccines
don't have the same sort of uh dose
characteristics that ordinary drugs do
uh it is sufficient to just to have a
very small amount of the uh antigen in
the system so that the immune system
will recognize it and develop antibodies
uh it's not that you're
giving uh a a tiny dog the same dose as
you're giving a big dog it's that a what
is sufficient for a tiny dog is also
sufficient for a very big dog uh so um
so the uh and as representative eron
pointed out uh the although there is uh
work being done on titer uh the way that
the consistency of the testing and the
way that that's interpreted uh is still
not solid enough to convince our state
vet that it's ready to go and I think
that our state vet is really on top of
controlling animal anal animal disease
in the state so I really trusted
judgment on
Penza so my question is kind of to
piggyback on what representative uh sopi
Kus um spoke about so I I not I don't
have a dog but and I don't have a lot of
knowledge but I've heard about titer now
for quite some time so how far away are
we I know that you followed up and said
that we're you know it's you could go in
one lab and it's this and another lab
but you said you put in a bill years ago
about this I mean I would see with
science and technology at this point
aren't we close because I know that
there's certain states that are using it
right now so I'm kind of um I'm just you
know my question is where where where we
at I've heard that we're a couple of
years away okay two three years away
okay I I don't know I mean it depends
who you talk to I
guess represent suus I think that it's
something as uh representative kraton
said we don't have a problem now and so
people are firm in that we don't have a
problem now and so it's budding up
against that because as a nurse in
Boston and a neuroscience nurse I saw we
had a patient that had rabies
and um it's horrible it's the worst
thing you ever saw and I myself um was
bitten by a cat when we were living in
Guam and the cat was froing at the mouth
and um it died with his teeth in my hand
and so they took the head and they had
to send it to the CDC in Atlanta but in
that meantime till they could find out
what was wrong with the cat I had to
have the r baby shots and um it's not
like it was a big deal but everybody was
making it like it was a big deal to me I
was like maybe 15 but I um it's nothing
to fool around with but people are
concerned
because it's um all of the doses come
packaged the same and so even if they
tried to
make the one of the testimonies the
doctor said and that's why when they
called me afterwards and asked why they
didn't get a better reception because
the doctor kept saying that well he
would write that he gave the dose but he
gave the weight specific dose and so it
was just a practice issue and I um I
can't deal with that as a nurse you
don't get to do things like that and so
I was very upset with him because I
think that this is a thing that it it's
time will come you know that we have
science and people will
understand the science and and then I
think that's when it will change but
it's going to be a slow thing
because the
downside is so awful and I pray that it
never happens to anybody that we know
and love because it's the most awful
thing and there's no coming back from
it y now in this bill it says um it
strikes out the line from statute that
says in addition when the animal is
outdo doors it shall be muzzled in a
manner approved by the local rabies
control Authority and I for me that's
kind of
um unsettling because we all do know
that uh dogs tend to get out from the
gate or you know jump the gate or if
they see something they're going to run
off and um you know musling is a tool
and I think that that's not a tool that
needs to be given up
um representative
smart um I I just would like to say that
um probably about 15 or 20 years ago we
had an outbreak of rabies in the state
of New Hampshire was pretty bad um in
the wild animal population and it did
not affect the domestic animals because
we vaccinate so I you know vaccinations
are very important whether it's um
dosage or however you want to look at it
also um a lot of there's a lot of
Manufacturers that make vaccines Rees
vaccines other vaccines and each
manufacturer has its own adant that it
mixes um to make it solu solvent so you
can give it as a
vaccine different animals just like
different people have different
reactions to different adant and so it
could be an adant issue when you have an
animal that's having a reaction so maybe
not the rabies vaccine itself the rabies
part of the vaccine but maybe the adant
part and maybe a different manufacturer
might be the way to go for
Penza being new on the committee and I
know that this is um these bills have
come forward over the years uh I just I
guess I'm kind of trying to understand
is there
is there an entity that's actually
really policing this like I mean do we
really need to strike out muzzle because
you're going to have someone that is
going to be like oh my gosh that dog on
you know 195 Smith Lane doesn't have a
rabies vaccine and it's not muzzled like
is that really
happening it's hard to say I mean we do
have Animal Control Officers who are
aware of dogs in their area who
have the exemptions and from what I
understand um let's see
um Dr Crawford I had asked him how many
dogs currently have rabies exemptions in
New Hampshire and when he ran last ran
the data March 2023 there had been 1628
exemptions issued in the 15 years since
the exemption process was implemented
some number of those were repeats from
prior years um but that means it there
would be at least 110 exempt dogs and
cats in New Hampshire based on
legislative changes last year they don't
get involved with the renewal process as
much um so you know there are dogs that
we are aware of that for one reason or
another um don't don't react well to the
rabies vaccination so they have an
exemption and I think the animal Control
Officers in those areas are aware of who
those are do they go to these people's
houses every day and make sure that
they're muzzled and that they're in
isolation probably not but seeing as um
you know we have a protocol in place and
statute I think that that that makes a
statement and many people will take that
pretty seriously I agree yeah
representative
Katon yes ma' and that's a a great
question represent potenti I would flip
it to the other way from a if something
does happen and say your dog does get a
an exemption and the BET says okay well
if your dog's outside you got to have a
muzzle on it okay it's up to you to do
that but if the dog does get away and it
doesn't have a muzzle on it then the
state has a recourse because you were
told to get this exemption these are the
rules you fail to follow the rules that
so rather than someone looking in
someone's backyard for this dog it's if
you violate it and something does happen
then then we have something to to fall
back on and I I think that's fine so
representative kto thank you actually uh
representative kraton basically said the
same thing uh I was going to speak to
Yes um because as a dog owner I know
that when my rabies are due it's one of
the things that I'm adamant about
because if my dogs get Loose as they
sometimes do CH going after whatever
they see in the woods um the fear for me
is if they ever bit somebody and they
weren't up to date on their
Ries I mean I could be
liable uh and it would affect my entire
you know everything so I think anybody
that's a responsible dog owner who has
an exemption will be following the law
just knowing
that representive Murray uh thank you
madam chair I also think it's important
to note that in this conversation about
uh rabies exposure and musling whether
it's an exempt animal or not there are
circumstances in which animals are fully
vaccinated for rabies have encountered
an animal that's suspected to be rabid
and is placed in quarantine and the
muzzle requirement is there as well so I
would just you know remind folks that I
think we're all again on the same page
here but there are other circumstances
in which um that is an appropriate um
set of uh circumstances that requires
it representative Howard thank you madam
chair I just wanted to um regarding the
the um the rabies outbreak of several
years ago I just wanted to commend the
committee for um for not making it so
that raccoons can't be pets because they
were the big purveyors of the the r
episode
before okay any further discussion I
think um I think we're pretty much um on
the same page with with that bill and um
you know while
I have some compassion for the issue of
uh you know having an older dog that's
sick and maybe you can't you have
trouble keeping a muzzle on them because
they're vomiting because of their
illnesses or whatever um you know I
think there's there's a a bit of
discretion here you work with your
Animal control officer on on how to
manage that properly within the
guidelines and
I I don't think that there's a you know
a need to strike out all of this uh
stuff from our from our current law so
that's kind of where I am with
that and uh the last bill that we wanted
to talk about uh that we heard in
committee is uh the architectural paint
recycling bill which is
hp504 and I invite representative Murray
to talk about that thank you madam chair
this is a concept that I think um while
I can't speak for other members I'm
actually really excited excited to see
this before our committee um for a
couple of reasons I know that my
wheelhouse has sort of been Solid Waste
Management and also then this the
conversation around um paint recycling
um and we know that there is a
significant portion of paint AR
architectural paint that is making its
way into landfilling uh landfills and um
some best practice methods that I think
are starting to be more widely accepted
as an maybe uh less preferable
um disposal method is is dumping it into
kitty litter and adding weight to our
tonnage and our land filling so this
program would really be an opportunity
to sort of stand up uh another um
smaller form of extended producer
responsibility um we know that there are
other programs throughout this um the
nation that um paint care has managed
and works I have gone back and looked at
previous iterations with the
subcommittee of the um legislation
thanks to Kristen grant our researcher
um and there are some things that are
lacking in the current piece of
legislation that we do need to work on I
understand that um there are
conversations about you know what
direction we need to go here if it's
possible to get a working piece of
legislation I'd like to give that um
some you know more time here to get to a
place where um we can get something that
um maybe gets a little bit further than
it did and in previous iterations it had
made it all the way into the Senate so I
would like to be able to work on that
representative com thank you madam chair
and thank you representative Marie for
really working on this um do you think
an interim study on this would be
helpful so that we can really delve into
this and come out with a really good
piece of legislation in the
fall thank you for the question um if I
may Madam chair sure oh thank you um I
do do think that that is um something
that may be up for discussion but I do
want to continue to look at perhaps
maybe an initial model piece of
legislation outside of what existed in
this bill filing as a uh vehicle for
kind of starting over again in a way
that um the American codings Association
and other entities at departments can
support something that is right for New
Hampshire so to say I'm open to that
conversation I would like to have a few
more days
to ponder that concept if I may okay
well the thing is um so our bills need
to be out of committee I Believe by the
21st and I was looking at executing this
bill on March 13th next week do you
think that any Amendment would be
available by then or um our last
otherwise our last exec session is going
to be March
19th so um if you don't feel that we
could come up with a comprehensive
Amendment then I think interim study
would probably be the way to go with
that um represent Bixby yeah I think
that um it makes sense to
uh see if we can get something together
uh in the next uh week and a half and uh
and you if at that if if when we get to
the um that final exec session on the
19th if it is in fact not ready to go
then we can then we should consider the
interim study but but I think that uh we
may be able to pull something together
within that time okay representative
sofikitis
um just a housekeeping ISS could you uh
Define architectural
paint
sure so to your point architectural
paint is anything that could be used
interior exterior and most specifically
what we heard in committee around this
bill was around um the potentially
hazardous um paints not water soluble
paints so
yeah okay representative ger thank you
madam chair Penza yes I I I I'm hopeful
that we can actually to representative
Murray's Point representative Big's
Point actually come up with something
within the time frame that we're looking
at here because with paint cares for
example these programs exist right in a
lot of places we're not Reinventing the
wheel and in fact to you know they have
a specific program and you kind of have
to as I understand it do it the way they
do it uh for example uh and I think it's
a good example of epr because it's an
industry
driven example of epr right so I think
there are there are lots of good
examples of this in practice and so I
think that we should on a relatively
short timeline be able to uh map out
something that could work as a test or
pilot program um here thank you
representative
Penza so I was there for the our little
yeah so it was um it went really well do
you have kind of um an idea in your head
of how you would mod ify it so we could
push this through now instead of going
to interim study you know
I there's a couple things that I have in
my head and I just want to know if we're
all kind of on the same page
representative Murray yeah thank you for
the question I do think that there are
some specific concerns that the American
codings Association had with sort of
pieces of maybe previous iterations that
didn't make it into the current
iteration um as well as um you know I I
do want to be very intentional I heard
the members point about making sure that
there were considerations given to all
sorts of sizes of of paint providers um
whether they were smaller or larger
entities um so I do want to talk with
the folks to make sure that we're we're
being mindful to to that and if there is
an exemption for some smaller areas or
maybe um modifications that make sense
under uh the codings Association
framework that's where I would like to
representative H Haskins did you add
your hand up before yes thank you madam
chair I was thinking about the testimony
of Sarah silk who's here today from
wolfboro and I was really impressed with
the idea that um
these these programs do exist as has
been said and I second everything
representative Murray said and actually
even some grants that are available so I
don't know how that could work in into
what we'd like to come up with but I
think it's it's exciting to believe that
we could really do better because it
does indeed impact our landfills with
all this sand and kitty litter
representative maray additionally I had
an interesting thought about this when
we're talking about um affordable
housing and the way to sort of have a a
conversation around other ways to um
have products and and um things
available that are more affordable
what we heard in testimony through paint
care is that some of these products are
sold at a lower cost and are available
to individuals um and it keeps them out
of the landfill and it keeps sort of a
broad spectrum of products available to
a lot of individuals and I think that it
has the potential for being a win-win
for lots of
folks any other discussion on this
bill so okay so I guess um work will
continue on
hp504 and um I guess I will put uh
schedule it for uh exec on Tuesday March
19th which would be our last exec
session day um and if it's got an
amendment that's ready um then we could
pass that out um and if not then we
could inter room study it I
suppose and um but I I think I would
like to
um
include a further discussion uh about
that next week when we do our work
session um on Wednesday March 13th
because you can give us an update on on
where you are with the amendment on that
okay alrighty
good uh that pretty much concludes um if
unless anybody else has any other
comments or questions on
anything um that pretty much concludes
the bills that we wanted to disc discuss
today and
um we will have another work session
tomorrow morning to discuss uh the bill
we're going to hear this afternoon as
well as the two other landfill bills
that we had uh heard uh and didn't
really have much time to discuss in the
previous work session so um that that's
going to happen tomorrow
morning and um I guess we're done with
our work session and we have time to
have an early
lunch all
right huh 1300 here 1300 yeah come back
at one o'clock and we will then at one
o'clock military yeah 1300 okay okay so
um yeah at one o'clock then we will uh
we will
reconvene and I have a visit from the
clerk
okay
which three are we doing this
afternoon
one
okay good afternoon everyone welcome
welcome to environment and
agriculture I'm chair uh representative
Judy Aaron and I want to welcome you all
I want to thank you all for coming out
today and testifying on this very
important
bill um I recognize that um we have a
very large crowd today we have a a fair
number of pink slips or pink cards if
you intend to speak I would appreciate
you fill out a pink card and pass it up
as soon as possible so we have a whole
have them all um a couple of rules for
us um after the sponsor of the bill
introduces the bill uh we will be
inviting individ we will be calling
people up individually from the pink
cards and I'm I'm going to be setting
because we have so many people here and
so many pink cards I am going to be
setting testimony at three minutes
uh at that point the committee will um
take the opportunity to ask you
questions they may or may not ask you
questions um my vice chair is going to
be um letting you know what your time is
by uh when you get to the two-minute
Mark he'll show a yellow when you get to
the three minute uh we're close to the
three minute he'll Flash the pink uh the
orange one so that you are aware of the
time
um and that's pretty much uh how we will
um proceed
today and I also want to make it
clear that we are all to be respectful
of everybody's um positions and what
they have to say I would uh expect that
nobody would uh make any disparaging
remarks against any particular people or
or
organizations and um let's just hear
what you have to say your experiences
we're interested in hearing your
expertise or um just your opinion on
this particular piece of legislation
just this bill um and um and that with
that I am going to open up the
hearing for HB
1102 which is relative to the de to the
definition of animal
cruelty and I
am U happy to hear our sponsor uh
representative Reed uh introduce this
bill to the committee so good afternoon
and thank you thank you madam chair and
thank you for your opening remarks um
and uh thank you honorable members of
the committee for the record my name is
Ellen Reed I Rec I represent Rockingham
10 which is New Market and new
fields for me the Genesis of this bill
goes back over 20 years ago when I
watched a televised News segment
covering a woman who had originally had
a single cat that had a deformity of its
front paws so it kind of sort of looked
like a mangled kangaroo it had very
short front paws that were twisted and
she inbred that cat with its uh
relatives until she had dozens of what
she called twisty
cats and wanted to registered this as a
recognized breed and I thought good God
and it would I think everyone who saw
that piece the the understanding was
this was ridiculous that this was
inflicting cruelty in the name of
wanting to start a new breed or or breed
an animal and then sell the progyny um
and I think it was universally seen as
ridiculous um I like many people in the
room on both sides of of this bill
thought that recognized breeds I didn't
really question the idea breeds are
breeds um Registries are doing the right
thing they obviously care about the
animals uh flat noses are cute long
backs are cute snoring and grunting is
cute and this is fine and I thought this
way for most of my
life um when I found out that many of
the breeds that we consider to be normal
breeds actually suffer by definition you
usually of how they have been bred
suffer from a slew of awful awful
medical conditions not just dogs and I
want to be very clear that the bill
covers all animals because it does
happen in many different
species um and it's not just brachy
which we'll get into but they suffer
from deformities that were intentionally
bred for their extreme appearance
extreme
Aesthetics when when I found this out I
connected it back to that weird news
story that I had seen with the twisty
cats and I thought why are we doing this
is it is it the case that yes this one
woman tried to do the twisty cat thing
but in fact this has been this kind of
while so it turns out my experience was
not unique in fact many many people who
own especially calic dogs these are
flat-faced dogs and cats um felt like I
did felt like these breeds were normal
things that their behaviors and their uh
appearance were normal and healthy for
the breed um and then they bought a
puppy usually a registered puppy um and
then they experienced what it's really
like for most people who have an animal
like this you have received probably I
I'm wagering I obviously don't have
access to all the testimony you've
received directly um probably hundreds
of emails from people who own these
animals and thought that this was a cute
breed whatever breed they got and
thought it was great and bought you know
usually at a great price bought a puppy
perhaps a kitten sometimes a horse and
then went wow I can't believe these
deformities were intentionally
bred so since then I've learned that
especially in American breeding
practices uh and breed Registries in
America um we have over many many
decades pursued this unending pursuit of
extreme Aesthetics extreme Aesthetics so
if a short nose is short nose is
desirable in a breed and even shorter
nose is even better or if a long back is
desirable an even longer back is better
and the thing about the extreme and I
don't want to like pretend that I'm
saying something that that it's it's not
accurate the word extreme comes up in
the the breed registry uh confirmation
standards repeatedly extremely short
nose extremely this extremely that and
this creates a chasing after an Ever
bigger um more extreme confirmation and
over the decades the effect is
eventually we get to a point where that
extreme confirmation is not compatible
with healthy life you cannot just keep
going more and more extreme with certain
features of the body and have that
individual be able for example to
breathe or be able to walk or reproduce
or many many other different things
which I'll get
into and unfortunately many Registries
encourage this um like I said they use
the word extreme in their own
confirmation standard so it creates this
will I want to be clear that the bill
itself is not breed specific and it does
not ban the owning or adopting of any
animal any animal whatsoever what it
says is that you cannot sell for profit
nor intentionally breed intentionally
which of course is a criminal um
liability word any two individuals with
the same deformity that cause that
causes suffering so that's that's
literally
it now I want to get into uh well let me
just stay on that for a second the the
the idea that this is going to mean like
I'm going after specific breeds that
people won't be able to breed those
breeds anymore that is not true people
can still breed they just have to breed
two individuals that don't have the
identical deformity that causes
suffering the problem is because once
again that chasing after the ever more
extreme confirmation in some breeds the
ones that are registered as pure bread
have too limited a genetic pool so what
it means is that in order to continue
breeding those breeds breeders may have
to introduce um individuals that have
healthier confirmation standards that
may not be papered as purebred according
to the registry of their choice but
there are many many pushes around the
world and in this country to do just
that um in the handout that I passed out
there is a page that gives an example of
the difference between an American conf
a typical American confirmation standard
and and one of these individuals that is
bred it is the second no third to last
page the individual on the right is a uh
Blue Ribbon award-winning show
dog you can see that that nose is
completely flat like a wall with his
forehead the that's on the left the
individ on the right is from hobu French
bulldogs and he has a snout and here's
the
thing pushing to go back to healthier
breed standards is not a new thing
because almost every single one of these
breeds originally had a much much
healthier breed confirmation standard
you can see this in photographs as young
as 50 years ago these dogs had noses you
can see this in paintings even going
back hundreds of years years where for
example Bulldogs had noses they had to
they were bred for athletic originally
bred for athletic activity so the idea
that we have gotten so far away from
those healthy breed standards to the
point that we are intentionally
inflicting suffering because it's cute
is what we're trying to go out after not
the idea of breeding not any particular
breed yes you can still breed all these
breeds you just have to do it in a way
that you you are not intentionally
creating
suffering so I list as one example and
it's just a for example it's including
but not limited to
brachy which is the term for a short
nose um this is what is common amongst
like French Bulldogs Boston Terriers
pugs um also Persian cats things like
that the thing is is that I think we
look at them like oh they just have a
short nose big
deal when they have short when they have
bred to shorten the
nose the bone and especially the soft
tissue the soft pallet didn't go
anywhere so what that means and you can
see there's multiple x-rays throughout
this handout what that means and and
pictures of skulls what that means is
all of that tissue all of that matter
that would have gone into a full muzzle
has been shoved into to basically
flatness and usually this causes what is
called um
braic obstructive Airway syndrome
boas the majority of these flat-nosed
breeds suffer from some level of boas
and there's a chart in here that goes
over three different breeds French
Bulldogs in particular 90% of all French
bulldogs have some level of boas now
here's the thing about boas I know that
the owners of these breeds think that
the snoring the grunting this the the
constant sounds coming from the
breathing of their animal is cute and
normal they will call it normal for the
breed and I guess it is normal because
it is standard in the breed and that's
kind of the problem but everyone knows
that if you have a clear pipe and you
push air through it it doesn't make a
gurgling sound
it only makes a gurgling sound if
there's something obstructing it if you
go to your doctor and you're constantly
sound your lungs are constantly sounding
snorting grunting gurgling your doctor's
going to say there's something wrong and
we know this because we all know of a
condition called Sleep Apnea if you
snore a lot there's something going on
and you're not getting oxygen and in
fact very many of these breeds the
individuals will adopt unorthodox
sleeping positions they will usually
sleep sitting up there's several
pictures of this phenomenon they will
sleep sitting up and with something
lodged in their mouth to help them get
more air as they
sleep and the thing is is that the the
owners of these breeds often consider
this to be AC cute Behavior because it
it I guess it kind of looks cute but
when you realize that they're doing it
because they literally can't breathe
that they stop breathing when they sleep
any other way then you realize that you
are actually in have inflicted suffering
so the fact that there is a grunting
snorting sound just from breathing just
from breathing is simple
physics in humans by the way and and
what that also means is that very many
times they cannot run we'll get into
grading and and and how they determine
that um and they also can't cool
themselves because panting is required
to cool um in dogs and if they can't
breathe properly and they don't have um
access and I have a veterinarian who can
go into more detail I'm sure access to
the the parts of the the structures that
actually help with the cooling then they
can't properly cool themselves so very
many of these breeds can't be exposed to
even moderately warm weather again it's
individual to individual you may have
very many people go not my dog not my
dog that's great then this wouldn't
impact them if they are truly breeding
healthy healthy animals this bill will
not impact
them but it's not just I I considered
listing boas specifically because I'm an
asthma sufferer and I have a lot of
sympathy for people who can't breathe or
animals who can't breathe um as the
example saying boas is the example but
really brail doesn't stop at boas
there's a whole slw of problems that
come with braisy in humans it is called
robinow syndrome and um I was advised to
not give you pictures of individuals
human individuals that have robinow
syndrome because it might be too
upsetting but um if you want to look up
pictures and see the medical conditions
that are associated with that condition
feel free and just imagine would we ever
say it's okay for two human beings to
intentionally intentionally trying to
create that condition it would be absurd
and that is what we accept without
question in
animals other conditions that go along
with
braisy very often their their craniums
cannot contain their brain matter so
they actually have incredible pressure
put on their brain and brain stem um
this is true of a lot of braches spyic
dogs uh apparently in a study done in
Norway I believe
100% 100% of King Charles cavaliers
spaniels suffered from this to the point
that they all all of them every
individual had constant headaches from
the time that they were born to the time
they
died and this was done without care so
because of that Norway actually banned
the entire breed I don't think we should
ban a breed I think we should change the
breeding practice so that we have
individuals that do not suffer also that
goes along with braisy eye issues many
of the species again all that matter
gets pushed into a smaller skeleton so
it doesn't go anywhere so the eyes are
still the same but the skull is T is
smaller so many of them have bulging
eyes that cause eye issues many of them
have gastrointestinal problems and throw
up frequently many of them have nerve
conditions skeletal conditions tear duct
conditions they're folds of skin because
again the skin didn't go anywhere it's
just on a smaller skeleton so that's
what creates those very adorable folds
but they get
infected um severe severe dental
problems because again way too many and
two large teeth on a smaller
skull um and as a an article that was
just covered by like less than a month
ago it was covered by every major
newspaper the Boston Globe New York
Times you name it um and around the
world in a study done out of England
they determined that these breeds
actually only live like seven eight
years on average many will live longer
but some will live much much shorter
because again not everybody all those
hundreds of emails you got from people
who who thought the best things about
these breeds but then got an individual
bought a registered puppy and then they
had to pay tens or in some cases
hundreds of thousands of dollars to get
surgery just so the animal could survive
not everybody can afford that so some of
these individuals don't live seven eight
years so in smaller breeds usually the
smaller the breed the longer lived it is
but with these conditions these animals
don't live even the the the life
breed so I want to connect with how this
is
that Madam chair I I I really
appreciated your comments at the
beginning about being respectful and I
don't know but I'm hearing very
disrespectful comments behind me so I
don't know if it's time to remind the
people behind me oh I'm sorry I have not
heard anything so but I would remind
everybody to please um be respectful
thank you thank
you
yeah there are some empty seats over
here and uh in the
fine yeah there should not be anybody
sit standing behind uh committee members
so please find a seat or you will have
here
Reed representative Reed when you're
ready thank you so much Madam chair I
appreciate that
um The Suffering that these animals face
on a daily basis pretty much on a minute
to minute basis is as real as the
suffering that you could inflict by
hitting or otherwise um obviously cruel
actions upon your animal so if I were to
for example strangle my dog for five
minutes put it into a state of of panic
make it struggle where it's trying to
fight to get into a position where it
can continue to breathe that would be
cruelty and I could and would should at
least be arrested for that and charged
with
it that feeling is identical to the
feeling that these animals who are bred
with conditions that are known to cause
this exact kind of suffering that
feeling is identical and so to
intentionally create an animal that will
live its entire life with a condition
like this is the same cruelty as
purposely inflicting pain after the
animal is born it's the same pain the
same
intentionality of course that is
cruelty now as far as
opposition I knew that when I put this
in it is not the first push like this
but it is the first state level push
there have been many um countries that
have gone after this in fact the term is
called torture breeding uh countries on
different levels have uh Netherlands and
Norway I already mentioned have gone
after torture breeding breeding of
animals to intentionally to have
characteristics that they know will
cause suffering um also different
municipalities across this country it's
also like I said there are new breed
Registries with healthier breed
standards that are trying to push uh
these breeds back to a a healthier
version but I understand that um that
putting this in being the the first time
this is being done on the state level
is uh shocking and perhaps upsetting to
many people um especially people who are
in the breeding community so breeders
Registries and reproductive
veterinarians I did mention that many of
these breeds cannot breed on their own
they cannot reproduce on their own so a
lot of these breeds are almost entirely
dependent on veterinarians to assist
with either artificial insemination and
or um C-sections because they can't give
birth so I understand that community and
this is normal for them like I said once
upon a time it was normal for me I
didn't question it either but I'm really
hoping that people who say that they
care about their animal because you will
get I think you said about 50 people
coming up to say they love their animal
I'm really hoping that they will open
their hearts and kind of drop the you
know we come into these committee rooms
with a lot of defensiveness a lot of you
know presumptions about the other and
the enemy I'm hoping that people who
truly love their animals will just stop
and let this in that if you
intentionally breed a characteristic
that you know will cause this problem
then that is not a loving action and
there are ways to do it better it's not
like you know you have to give it up
give up the breed give up breeding you
can do it but you can do it
better so some of the opposition you
will
hear um and like I said almost all of
whom will have a a personal
representative uh Reed I would caution
you um on supposing what people may or
may not say and I would hope that you
would stick to um the purpose and
intention of your bill and steer away
from what you think people may or may
say in their testimony or what they may
or may say in defense or in support of
this bill I appreciate that comment
Madam chair as you know it is standard
practice to um um address opposition
since I will not have a chance to come
back at the end and address the
opposition also this is not supposed
this is based on social media posts
letters that the committee has heard
that I was copy that I was copied on and
um articles so these are things I've
already seen as
arguments thank you so um most of the
opposition again many of whom have a
financial interest in continuing
breeding as they do um but you will hear
that first of all
um
sorry that their dogs are healthy if
their dogs are healthy this doesn't
impact them because again the language
of the bill specifically is preventing
breeding two individual not even just
one like you could still have breed one
individual with a deformity that causes
suffering but you just can't breed two
that have the same deformity that causes
suffering
so if their animals are healthy and
they're doing it the right way and
they're not suffering then this bill
does not impact
them they also say they love their
animals and I'm happy to hear that but
if if they know what they're doing is
causing suffering then I would argue
that I have greater love because I don't
want them to cause suffering to those
animals some will argue I've seen this
that it's unconstitutional I I don't
think there's any kind of um legal
background to that whatsoever obviously
we do all kinds of laws especially and
regarding animals and what is
cruelty um I I I as a as a teacher of
the United States Constitution um I can
say there's nothing in the Constitution
regarding animal breeding
practices um and some will actually
acknowledge that there is a severe
problem because there is a severe
problem it's really undeniable um
but they will say that the the answer is
not to legislate it the answer is
education um and private breed
Registries changing their uh
confirmation standards which I hope they
do but we know that that has not worked
in fact that the the trajectory has been
continually to get more and more extreme
because again those extreme
Aesthetics the more extreme you are the
more desirable which means you can
charge more for the
progyny they do have they have created
an an independent grading system
specifically for the boas the breathing
issues um but too too too few individual
dogs are graded according to that most
breeders don't test them according to
that scale I applaud the ones that do um
and that do and then only breed dogs
that but again the breathing is only one
aspect of braisy there's many many many
it turns out when you shorten a
and don't shorten everything else that
goes along in the body there are a lot
of problems with
that and braisy is just one of very many
different problems that very many
different breeds have because of the
ever never-ending pursuit of those
extreme
confirmations so I I really really
hope that the people in the room who
maybe came in with perhaps anger I don't
know defensiveness I don't know can kind
of hear what the intent here is and kind
of hear what the science behind now
forget the science forget the science it
says a deformity that causes suffering
that's all you need to hear if you are
intentionally creating a deformity that
causes suffering how can that be okay I
think anyone who comes up and goes I
should be allowed to do that I do that I
intentionally create deformities that
cause suffering in animals I do that and
I want to keep doing that if anyone
essentially says that they are telling
on themselves they are telling on
themselves so in closing I would just
like to say that it's obviously cruelty
to intentionally inflict suffering on an
animal whether it's from its birth or
afterwards and we legislate against
cruelty because it's unethical and and
we have to we we have to do the right
thing as
legislators so I'm happy to take
questions but I ask that you um fairly
and openly consider
ktoa thank you madam chair and thank you
representative for being here um and
testifying
um would you know at a young age that
these animals are not
healthy in some cases you might and in
some cases you might not I'm not sure
but you do know by the time that they
are breeding age again I have a
veterinarian that would be happy to
answer more thoroughly follow follow up
so what you're saying is as a puppy when
they're three months old or something
you wouldn't know that they're having a
breathing
issue for severe breathing breathing
issues I imagine that you actually would
right um but again I'm not a
veterinarian and I do have one that can
answer more thoroughly having said that
I want to be very clear this is not at
all about going after breeders who sold
their puppies and then later there was a
condition found that's I understand a
lot of people have come to this issue
because that's what happened to them but
this isn't giving like a ride of like
civil action against a breeder this is
just saying once they're breeding age
you cannot intentionally that means
knowingly as in you know what the
condition is and these animals have that
condition and you know it breed two
individuals with identical deformities
deformities so not any other condition
deformities that cause
suffering representative kto thank you
yes please thank you m Madam chair and
thank you again so I'm just looking at
the language because it says so if you
sell an animal that has a birth
deformity that causes suffering you're
in violation of this um your you're it's
considered animal cruelty even if you
don't know that the
animal has a birth deformity according
to this or you intentionally breed which
that part I can understand um with the
intent to sell two individual animals of
the same birth deformity but if you sell
an animal that has a birth deformity
that causes suffering and you sell it
unknowingly you're still guilty is that
correct thank you so much representative
for pointing out that I had the as you
may know in criminal justice law there
are four mental states of C
culpability um and that whilst the
intentional was put on the breeding that
it was skipped on the birth deformity
I'm happy to add that and I'm glad to
hear that you're likely to support it if
I
do representative
kulan thank you for taking my question
and thank you madam chair just to stick
to the subject matter I'm hearing the
word suffering a lot
and with relation to boas like who is
going to determine suffering in like
each individual case would it be the
courts who's going to figure it out
thank you for the question I did
struggle with putting this language in
how um how specific to get and you may
recall me being here a few weeks back
the debate on um how specific versus how
broad do we write language um and it is
always very intentional like balance
between intentional ambiguity and
specificity um at that point I was
arguing about listing specific um like I
did with braisy here as an example
listing specific um other practices that
were cruelty um and I was uh the
argument against that was that we
already have a very broad vague
definition of Cruelty that includes the
word mutilation of course we don't ever
apply that to things like declawing or
ear cropping or tail docking we don't
consider that so that is the danger of
being too broad and too vague um and of
course the problem with being too
specific is that you might leave
something out I went with this and I'm
happy to go and get the medical
community definition of suffering if
that's what the committee will support
um but I went with this because it's
cleaner because I find that when I argue
for a bill in committee if I get too
specific then the specifics get
questioned and if I'm too broad then the
broadness is questioned and often times
no matter what I provide and what was
asked really whoever was asking for that
was just against it to begin with um and
and there's no way to make that
individual happy so um if the committee
you or anybody else would prefer like
say a medical community's definition of
uh suffering or say like a doctor's
letter a doctor's statement or an
assessment um or a judge however you
want to go about that I'm happy to do
that because I just want to get at the
suffering that's being being inflicted
on
Penza thank you for taking my question
so it might be the veterinarian that
would answer this but it kind of Falls
underneath representative ktoa if right
now if someone if a breeder sells that
animal and it has um that kind of
breathing deformity let's just use that
one um
upon um upon purchase of
is there something you know are they are
they able to get a health certificate
for example right now if that if they
have that breathing
deformity so yeah I think maybe the the
vet might be better able to answer that
but really what we find because again um
even with breed Registries very
frequently they have an internal like
grading system or what have you in order
to register that
individual however as representative
comah pointed out you may not know that
as a as a baby but also I hear and I'm
not a breeder so I can't speak
specifically to this I hear that you
know it's not like a doctor that
literally comes out and like tests it
for all the wide range of conditions
that could possibly exist so you know I
I what I'm arguing is that the breed
Registries do have an incentive to go
ahead and certify and certify ever more
extreme confirmations and and that
incentive kind of uh goes against maybe
valuing the health of the
animal representative Davis and then
Bixby thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question uh so far
we've we've talked only about uh animals
that that have potential breathing
issues now how about hip displacer or or
larger breeds that are susceptible to
heart problems and short-lived you know
we're talking how how would that affect
this so it has to be a deformity and if
this committee really wanted to get more
expansive than this bill then I would
support that too but it has to be a
deformity and it has to cause suffering
so not necessar a short life isn't
necessarily suffering um because they're
like Great Danes only live like seven
years right versus a smaller breed which
might could live like 20 so um as far as
hip dysplasia or those extreme sloping
backs or extremely long backs of other
breeds I'm certainly not like trying to
pick on any particular breed all of that
should be covered if it's causing like
with the very long backs a lot of times
that you know people human beings get
back pain the longer your back is the
more likely you're going to have extreme
back pain and if you were born with a
ridiculously long back intentionally
bred to have an like a back much much
longer than your legs you're likely
going to have lots of lots of back pain
so yeah that should all be covered
because those are deformities that cause
suffering but again could there be
individuals within that breed that don't
have that suffering yeah and then you
could breed those like I said with the
boas specifically with French Bulldogs
90% of French bulldogs suffer from boas
some level of boas but that means 10%
don't so you can bre the 10% and bring
in new genetic um uh individuals for for
uh more genetic a larger genetic pool to
make that breed healthier
representative
Bixby so I'm wondering how this is going
to be
enforced thank you for the question
representative um I find that you asked
that question a
lot so I foresee it being enforced uh
the way that we enforce many things that
kind of are potentially vague especially
a lot of Cruelty issues so it it does
fall down to people reporting
um and that's true of a lot it's true of
domestic violence it's true of a lot of
things that people have to report what
they see and then somebody
investigates but I mean you could argue
right now that our cruelty statute might
cover this already it would be a very
broad uh
interpretation um but it's not
enforcable and like really enforceable
to prosecutors unless we specify it so
will there be issues with people saying
you know well I think the this person
may have done this yeah that could be an
issue for investigation you have to go
and look into things or what have you it
might be a not as cleancut as we would
like but it's better than not having it
a crime at all in which case nothing
gets
prosecuted any other questions in the
committee so um I do have a question in
um do do you you consider
bra a birth
deformity regy seil is a by definition
is a shortened snout in comparison to
the length of the skull but is that a
birth so that is a birth
deformity you consider that a birth it's
not my consideration it it is a birth
deformity it is they are genetically
bred to have shortened snouts in their
and really shorten skeletons
um all right that's so that's all I have
a question anybody
else okay seeing none thank you for
introducing the Bill thank you for uh to
the whole committee and to you madam
chair for um listening to my um in-depth
introduction sure thank you um I will
need to step out because I have um a
bill that I need to go uh attend to to
in another committee so I'm going to
step out for a few moments and I hand
over uh chairmanship to our uh
representative kraton but I will call up
speaker well good afternoon and uh it's
great to be back in Ena haven't been
here for almost two years and you guys
are doing a great job so for the record
my name is Senator Howard Pearl I uh
represent District 17 I live in the
Great town of Lowden I am here to oppose
House Bill
1102 and my main reasons for opposing
this is you know I was a former owner of
a boxer I love the dog he was a great
dog and I and I know that boxers have
this head shape and and it would prevent
folks like myself from having a dog like
that and uh he was a great dog had no
breathing issues uh you just had no
health
issues this bill threatens anyone
breeding boxers with the risk of
committing a crime and it would result
in no New Hampshire residents breeding
boxers or other breeds with this head
shape that's a
problem that that New Hampshire's always
been a very friendly state to breeders
and to animal agriculture when we start
putting in things in place like this we
we're really threatening that and that
is very much a part of our
heritage I guess notably this bill does
not ban buying a boxer or any other dog
with a short and wide skull so if I
wanted to have another Boxer if this
bill were to pass the only way I could
do it would be to travel out of state
and get one you know and wouldn't be
able to get one from a local New
Hampshire breeder and over the many
years that I sat on this committee with
with many of you we've we've always
known and heard about the the great
relationships that our New Hampshire
breeders have with their customers and I
think this bill would put that in
property I that would be very
concerning you know when you when you're
selecting your dog's breeder you want to
be able to meet that local breeder you
want to be able to meet the puppy sire
that and and you want to be able to meet
the dam and you want to know who they
are and what you're buying and the
having the ability to see that is what
one of the distinct things that makes
New Hampshire great that we can have
those opportunities for our our buyers
of dogs to come and see the Breeders and
really get to meet them it that that's
something we want to be real careful to
protect
so when you uh you know local
communities should consider breeders an
asset they they're always great members
of our community many of them have been
here for for
Generations you know they're in the
unique position to Mentor new dog owners
and provide advice and detailed
information about the dogs they own and
sell and and that's very critical we we
see a lot of bills you know I did in the
house I I have in the Senate we see many
of them them and we're always looking to
try and make sure that our animals are
well taken care of and you know one of
the things I always remind everybody
there's nobody in this room that's
advocating for animal cruelty never
there never is what we're advocating is
for good responsible animal ownership
and the ability for owners to make
decisions for themselves and and this
bill challenges that and that that's one
of the problems that I have with it so I
think it would this bill would
unacceptably eliminate an option for a
New Hampshire residents to to see the
dogs and to buy the ones that they want
so I'm going to stop there because I'm
supposed to be in finance 45 minutes ago
so I'm going to run quickly and uh and
if it's all right with the committee I'm
really not going to take any questions
because I'm much later than I should be
but I appreciate the opportunity and I
appreciate you all being here this is
one of the issues that and all of these
animal cruelty issues are that you know
whenever we're considering legislation
it's a challenge and it and I just want
you to know that you know you're doing a
great job and we thank you for being
here and and I I hope you'll look at
this bill and realize that this really
is not right for New Hampshire it's not
what we want to set so thank you for
that Senator thank you for your
welcome next I'd like to call The
marula and if everyone can remember
minutes took me a minute to walk here
so uh thank you uh for giving me an
opportunity today to speak to you uh and
as Howard said it's great to have all
the representatives here uh and
listening to this bill I have several
issues with it um I I think the biggest
thing that people need to understand is
if you're going to purchase an animal a
dog for3 to
$6,000 uh I think you're going to do
your research and I can't imagine even
buying a dog for $600 without doing some
research on it so to assume that um to
make the assumption that people aren't
doing that is kind of strange to me the
Breeders as uh Senator Pearl said are
very important um I think that
uh we need to look at breeders the
they're ethical they're ethical breeders
and to continue to talk about
um information that is on the web or you
got from a veterinarian that's fine but
in the long run we all have to make that
decision it's was my choice to have a
bulldog I knew what I was getting into
when I purchased it uh it was my choice
and I have a
Frenchie uh she is cute um she doesn't
sleep the way was explained um she
sleeps a little differently but that's
not the issue I think what we're here
today to find out is how how do we move
forward with something like this uh and
as Senator pointed out um none of us in
this room on either side would be
comfortable hurting an animal so I think
we need to keep that in
Focus um I believe there's already a law
in the state now I served quite a while
ago so I'm not sure if it's still around
but there was a law in the state that a
breeder could not sell uh to another
breeder or not breed to another dog
rather um if there was a problem with
the dog and they could not sell that
particular animal to anyone and they
needed to tell people that so I believe
there is a law in place uh I would have
to check on that but I could be wrong so
I think that's something to keep in mind
that we can't we already have a law in
that I had so much to talk about but I
think everything has come out already um
I also think that uh we have have very
capable veterinarians in this state and
we don't need to be listening to
somebody from out of state or out of the
country um was mentioned a few times uh
that studies were done in the UK and in
Norway um you know I think that our
forefathers fought to keep those laws
out of our country and I don't think we
need it today we don't need a law that's
brought to us from someplace else or
feel that that's a place that we should
look to for
uh information we have very capable
people in this country that can give
that information to us
um I also think that I think you've hit
your three minutes three minutes okay
I'll I'll wrap it up so uh thank you so
much for giving me this opportunity I
would be glad to talk to anyone after
about why we purchase the dogs we have
and that they're very healthy uh as um
representative Reed said we would come
up and tell you how happy we are with
her dog and she's she's right in that
fact so thank you so much for having me
today
okay thank you um honorable past
representative uh marzulo we I I do want
to uh point out RSA 437 colon 5
regarding the transfer of animal and
animals and birds does say uh no leny
under the subdivision shall transfer
other than to a qualified veterinarian
or licensed animal shelter facility May
any maimed sick or diseased animal or
bird other than is permitted under RSA
437 colon 8 nor shall any lcy treat
inhumanely any animal or bird in his or
her care position possession or under
his or her control so I don't know if
that was the RSA that you were referring
to um but I do know that any animal that
is transferred does need a um health
certificate so presumably the
animal does have to be healthy when it's
sold um that being said we all recognize
that a health certificate sort of is a
snapshot in time um you cannot predict
what kind of conditions an animal is
going to
develop um be they you know caused by
congenital issues or or genetics or
anything else but um my question to you
is
um as so you have a French Bulldog now
yeah yeah and and has it had uh horrible
health issues as a result of its uh
breed no none at all um it's we've been
we were very careful at the breeder we
chose uh turned out that the breeder was
about four miles from my house which I
didn't even know about uh and we we
spent some time with him uh then we took
her took him took her to our
veterinarian and uh she checked her she
checked cozette is the dog's name she
checked cozette out and uh there was no
problems at all um the face is more open
so we believe it was bred the way we
would consider breeding dogs we bred
Chows a long time ago I'm not a breeder
today certainly but we were familiar
with those types of issues so no there's
been no problems at all with this dog
any other
questions see none thank you very much
for you coming today to testify thank
Chase good afternoon good afternoon
thank you for having
on I did want to speak to um as far as
people choosing and and buying from
readers people get them because they're
cute they don't always do their research
anyways my my just is just my personal
experience um I've always loved Bulldogs
since the first one I've met with my
customers I've wanted one for years
couldn't afford it as I got older I
could so I started doing my
research big difference from the old
English bulldog Britain English Bulldog
how they're breed here night and day
they're healthier in Britain they're
longer legs bigger snout here they have
trying to make the bum as Tiny as
possible the head as big as possible
they have to have not all of them some
of them have to have C-sections and if
they're a breeder that's constant scar
tissue and again not good for any animal
um the wrinkles the flat face um the the
soft pallet I belong to a bunch of um
bully breed rescues the stories are
horrific I'm not saying that all Bully
breeds have problems but the ones that
do are horrible people give up their
dogs they drop them off at a shelter
because they cannot afford the surgeries
to make them healthy um for instance
Long Island Long Island um bulldog
rescue you could look on their site and
see the horror stories they go on um the
the kind of running joke not joke if
you're going to get a bulldog you better
have $20,000 extra in the bank for
surgeries or really good insurance um I
am fortunate that my girl
has my girl has um she's healthy and she
can breathe and I would love to see see
the breeds go on um ethical that's all
it takes thank you thank you any
questions from the
committee seeing none thank you for
coming today thank you um I call Lisa
Freeman thank you for joining us today
thank you madam chair and thank you
committee for hearing my testimony I'm
I'm in front of you to ask you all to U
vote on in expedient to legislate on
this particular bill and I'll tell you
why um for 15 years I had a Shih Tzu and
the Shih Tzu was given to me I did not
purchase the dog from a breeder um but
before I even had the dog in my home I
did my research and found out that the
dog is in fact one of the brachos phalic
breeds um unfortunately um max um did
expire at 13 years old but not due to
anything attributed to being a
brachiocephalic dog he had conest of
heart failure at 13 years old um and it
was a blow to my family my family who
absolutely embraced this dog but also
knew of any of the health issues that
may come up and I wanted to give you a
brief history of what a shatu is and
that is the proper Chinese uh
pronunciation yitsu is in Chinese the
lion dog and they were breed
specifically in Tibet and Mongolia for
the Imperial family um they were
considered to be very spiritual dogs
according to the Buddhists and um the
emperor and the Imperial family kept
them because they represented The Souls
of any of the Fallen Buddhist monks
which I thought was very interesting in
1948 during the cultural revolution in
China uh Ma's regime killed every Shih
Tzu except for 13 and they were smuggled
into England and Norway to be bred and
then subsequently brought to the British
Isles and the United States that's
animal
cruelty having a brachiocephalic dog
does not equate animal cruelty what it
means is that dog is break your calic
and there are certain steps that you
take in order to keep that dog healthy
you clean their eyes you make sure their
teeth are clean you take them to the vet
regularly and I didn't need tens of
thousands of dollars to care for this
dog just regular maintenance and making
sure that he was well was not a stretch
for a beloved family pet and I am
currently on the lookout through every
adoption um agency in the United States
for an adult Shih Tzu um I lost Max
three years ago and recently lost my
beloved husband and I need a shih tzu
they are more to me than most people so
I thank you for your testimon allow me
to have the testimony and if you have
any questions I'd be more than happy to
answer them thank you any questions from
the
committee appreciate your testimony
thank
O'Brien
good
afternoon I've been frantically revising
my testimony because everything's being
said so bear with me my name is Joan
O'Brien and on behalf of the New
Hampshire animal rights league and our
members we are here to respectfully
request that the committee support House
Bill 1102 to end the the selling or
intentionally breeding of dogs with a
deformity that causes
suffering I'm going to focus on um
Breaky spelic dogs since that seems to
be the focus of the conversation around
this
bill it is highly distressing to know
that right now millions of dogs millions
of flat-faced dogs around the state and
country are struggling just to breathe
and more are being brought into the
world every day
as the bill sponsor explained extremely
well uh these dogs have um have they
they've been bred in a way that means
their anatomical features can't function
properly tinkering with
nature to produce dogs that serve our
needs whether it's for appearances or
function has upended survival of the
fitness the health of bralic dogs is so
precarious that most commercial airlines
won't even allow them to fly because so
many have died in
Flight while Veterinary intervention can
alleviate suffering from some dogs many
if not most will never be helped because
their suffering goes unnoticed or
unaffordable given the exponential
popularity of all these flat-faced dogs
we have on our hands a canine welfare
crisis
the Cris it's a crisis that warrants
legislative action to bring about as
Swift as possible an end to this type of
breeding as possible thank
you to close um I think the breed
Registries have kind of lost control of
enforcing
standards and the consumers are not
educated many don't even care about
registering their dogs visit one of New
Hampshire's puppy stores on a Saturday
and you will see for yourself so we
hopefully will support this Bill thank
you very
much thank you any questions from the
committee happy to take questions um I'm
interested to know if you are um if you
know what the breeding standards are for
these particular
breeds I did happen to carefully read
the breed standards for a pug in
preparing for this um
hearing about a 50-page document okay um
and did you find anything in the
breeding standard that would indicate
that if the dog was bred according to
the standard that it would be unhealthy
or sick or in a need of um
surgeries uh yes I did um I can't quote
it exactly but there
are the some of the standards include a
flattest face as possible uh that is by
so so the the standard actually says in
it the flat flattest faces possible yes
it
does okay and where did where did you
see this uh was this the American Kennel
Club has a link to the breed standards
for all the the popular dogs okay
um would you suggest that every
brachio brachio phalic dog is
unhealthy no certainly not okay so so
within the breed or
within I'm just trying to tease out that
brachio falic does not necessarily
equate to suffering that there is there
are very many healthy Shih Tzus and
Bulldogs and French Frenchies and Pines
and they're very healthy and there's no
problem so I I I'm I'm struggling with
that
because you know it it says here in the
bill sells an animal that has a birth
deformity that causes suffering such as
brachio and and and so it it seems to me
that um just because an animal is
brachio falic does not necessarily mean
that it's suffering that's true it it's
it by definition is deformity but not
necessarily causing suffering so you
might add to the end such as Brey saali
that causes
suffering okay thank you any other
questions representive
kraton yes Madam chair thank you and
thank you for your testimony I just to
amplify a little bit I think on what the
the chair was saying that so as I read
the bill it says two individual animals
with the same deformity but that doesn't
necessarily mean two Pugs that means two
pugs with
formity and so as you read this does
that mean you cannot breed for example
pugs this
legislation well I wish that the sponsor
were here to answer that question um I
think you would not be allowed to breed
two pugs who had a deformity causing
suffering that is the intention of the
legislation so that for a followup
followup so did then you read that you
could breed two pugs if they did not
have the theform
that's how the legislation reads I
believe okay thank
you represent ger thank you madam chair
and thank you for taking my question
this is followup to representative
kraton's question because there is the
two pugs right to parse the sentence two
pugs who have the deformity and then the
clause which follows that is that causes
suffering and this is where I get uh if
you could perhaps speak to how we Define
suffering and how this is going to be
determined because as again just parsing
that sentence it would seem to be that
you could breed two Pugs that have the
deformity if that deformity was judged
not to be the cause of suffering and
that raises a lot of questions about how
suffering is defined and as I said who
it is that is going to be determining
that so could you help me understand how
in practice that would work
yeah so um thank you um I think that
there are clearly some areas that need
to be ironed out uh we discussed earlier
a veterinarians assessment to determine
whether or not an animal is suffering um
that seems to be our best option right
now thank you thank you madam chair
representative Murray thank you um Madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question so when with regard
to asking a veterinarian then to take
that on are there implications to making
sure that that
assessment um is prior to breeding or
like how would that how would I guess to
uh representative German's Point that's
the question I guess yeah thank you I'm
I'm not a dog breeder I don't know too
much about how that world works you know
how how dogs are approved to breed or
not I know it's very well regulated I
would think you could insert something
in there that would you know um Ensure
that the animal didn't have a deformity
causing it to suffer before you allowed
bred representative
Bixby U have you had any experience with
animal cruelty
investigations I have not okay then I
will save my question for someone else
thank
you thank you any other questions from
the committee seeing none thank you
thank you I'd like to call uh Bernice
Sullivan
welcome thank you thank you madam chair
and members of the committee for uh
being here and and
listening um my name is Bernice Sullivan
um I live in Wentworth and um I'm here
as representing myself and also the
Irish Terrier Club of
America um I'm in opposition to HB 1102
for many reasons but what I would like
to speak about today is genetics and I'm
sure you all got up this morning and
thought I can't wait to hear about
genetics um but it's it it'll be very
brief um two of the things that breeders
can consider when breeding are phenotype
and genotype in basic terms phenotype is
what the animal looks like genotype is a
compilation of all the genes both
recessive and dominant that make up the
animal's
genome the scientific word that vets
used to describe short-nosed or
flat-faced dogs is brachy calic this
comes from two Greek words meaning short
and head brachy describes any dog
whose muzzle has a short or pushed in
appearance braches spyic is a word used
to describe
phenotype it is not a condition nor is
it a disease or a
deformity breeders are trying to produce
puppies that meet their breed standard
most breed standards arise from and
Encompass the original or current
purpose of the breed in no cases do
breed standards call for a breed to be
deformed or to breed dogs to suffer
language contained in HB
1102 including a word like braches spalc
which is descriptive of a type of skull
structure in a law about animal cruelty
is a false equivalency of a body
structure with a potential Health
complication which could
arise there are many illnesses or
injuries that can be linked to
structural issues is a breed with long
legs that is more apt to tear an ACL
deformed is a dog with short legs bread
to go into a small space to catch Vermin
deformed who is the Arbiter of what
constitutes these so-called
deformities this type of language and
legislation can lead to many more
problems many more problems will the
next prohibited phenotype be condr
dysplastic this could extend to
agricultural animals briefly condr
dysplasia describes animals with short
legs this phenotype is characteristic of
many breeds of dogs such as Cor ories
and doxins it is also present in Irish
Dexter cattle I used to breed Dexter the
condro displasia trait in Dexter is a
desired trait that came about because of
a gene
mutation it can also lead to dead
calves um I'm going to cut it short
because I know I'm approaching the end
but fortunately the genetic component
for this is a simple simple autosomal
dominant gene and there's only a one in4
chance if that can happen but there is a
genetic
test so breeders don't breed those
animals um this proposed language does
nothing to prevent cruelty it merely
muddles the waters around breeding and
creates potential to reduce genetic
diversity or even eliminate some reads
entirely thank you represent ger thank
you madam chair thank you for taking my
question I appreciate the uh
the science lesson is helpful uh and and
the clarification about a phenotype
we're talking about a phenotype when
we're talking a bracky uh calic animals
I'm just wondering does it in your
estimation make the bill any better if
it were to specify um rather than the
phenotype the syndrome that is often or
at times at least associated with the
phenotype right the brachy phalic airway
obstruction syndrome does it make it
better to say that you can't
intentionally breed two animals who have
the same syndrome which is by definition
a pathological condition right um that
would be very hard to determine ahead of
time because does that does that animal
develop it at one yearold twoy old
fiveyear old um you know many many dogs
are bred at two years of age so has it
developed at that it also is a is a
slippery slope kind of thing so if you
have um two to breeding animals and you
breed them and they have oh let's say a
a cancer Gene and you know there's a
history of uh
osteosarcoma and they produce dog
puppies that have that well you won't
know that right away but there's a that
there's that lurking genetic thing and
that's still that causes suffering um
but it's not something you can know when
you're breeding may I follow up follow
up sure thank you does the language in
the B Bill about intentionality however
deal with that because you're right you
may not know at two years when you breed
the dog and and in which case it's not
intentional even if that dog were to
develop the syndrome uh a couple of
years later I'm just trying to
understand I I I see difficulties and
trying to sort this out but I'm
wondering if intentionality covers the
specific example you just referred to
well yes and no because again if you get
back to the questions that were asked
about how does this get in forced and
you have um people reporting someone
because who's who's going to say what
the intention was when they
bred you know yes I know the genetic
Legacy of any dogs I breed um but I
don't know the percentage chance that a
certain recessive gene might come
forward um so there's there's that thank
much oh absolutely represent H Haskins
thank you very much and thanks for
taking my question I too was edified by
this conversation I have an important
question for you are Irish Terriers
Breaky calic not at all no I just called
it up on my phone because I wasn't
familiar with it I wanted to clear that
up okay no they're not um they there are
there is a genetic condition which we're
searching for a gene right now that um
could potentially cause suffering it's a
it's a um bladder stone type of thing
and um we try not to breed for it but it
can happen and until we find the gene we
can't eliminate it
entirely thank you representative
victory yeah so um this is sort of
getting into the the genetics a little
bit more uh is it possible that when you
are uh breeding for one particular trait
um let's say you're breeding for t
position uh and uh are there when you
select for that is it possible that you
will uh get other characteristics to
change at the same time because they're
linked absolutely like maybe pus goes
along with FY ears or something
absolutely and and a lot of that
breeding is an science and it's an art
and it's a lot of luck too um so yes
there are there are linked things and
sometimes you you can predict them and
sometimes you can't thank you any other
questions thank you ma'am appreciate
your testimony thank you for uh hearing
please thank you everyone thank you to
the committee uh my name is Eliza Berg
born and raised in sandwi New Hampshire
I'm here today to uh support this bill
and tell you about my dog
penny so I spent hours doing extensive
research on the French Bulldog breed and
spoke to countless potential breeders
those hours of research alerted me to
the potential challenges that we might
face having to be careful of her back
and watch out for IBD or introver table
disc disease being fastidious about
cleaning her wrinkles and tail pocket
making sure she doesn't get overheated
um due to her flat face I did not once
come across the term braches spyic
obstructive Airway syndrome or boas fast
forward a few months I had found myself
a preservation breeder in Ohio who owned
a dog that was The Sire for a litter of
puppies being raised by her friend in
mentee this breeder passed all the tests
I had learned to look for not breeding
for fad colors breeding to the standard
doing the right Health testing and so on
Penny was the smallest of the litter um
so the Breeders vet did some additional
testing on her she was cleared to come
home with us at 10 weeks just one week
after bringing Penny home she vomited
and collapsed on the floor one evening
we rushed her to the emergency pet
hospital Penny was extremely anemic and
received a blood transfusion to save her
life this began a multi-year journey to
diagnose penny with iron deficiency
anemia caused by internal bleeding that
still has an unknown cause she's since
had one more blood transfusion to save
her life around the same time that we
were struggling to get answers for her
anemia we became concerned concerned
with her breathing she snored to a point
where I could not fathom that she was
getting any Oxygen at all and would have
occasional bouts of regurgitation and
exercise intolerance thanks to a
Facebook group called balic breathing
awareness I quickly learned more about
boas and the surgical options available
to US penny saw one of the best soft
Tiss tissue surgeons in the Boston area
and had her soft pallet shortened and
her nostrils expanded these surgeries
are necessary because dogs like Penny
are bred so that their internal Airway
has become cramped and they spend their
lives struggling to get enough air into
their lungs Penny's story is a sad one
but as far as I can tell she's a success
story for a French Bulldog her symptoms
weren't that severe and she's had a
relatively happy life although we
continually uh worry about her and she
may need surgery again there are over
23,000 people in this Facebook group for
a while after her surgery I tried to go
on and answer people's questions giving
them support and the hope that I once
needed um to not despair
after a while uh it became too
depressing and frustrating to see every
day new people coming on not knowing how
to help their dogs that are suffering
and how many owners are woefully unaware
of the basics of boas and the options
for care penny has required over $34,000
in vet and testing costs pet insurance
bills hours spent educating myself and
advocating for my dog just so that she
can live what I hope is a comfortable
life there are tens of thousands of dogs
who don't have that luxury
thank you and I'm happy to answer any
questions representative C thank you uh
Mr chair and could I get a copy of your
testimony please thank
you any further
questions thank you ma'am appreciate
your
testimony if I could call uh Taylor
you
thank you Vice chairman kraton and
members of the committee for having me
today to speak to you about House Bill
1102 my name is Taylor llli and I am
here on behalf of the pet advocacy
Network the pet advocacy Network
represents the responsible pet Care
community in New Hampshire and Across
the Nation so today we are here to urge
you to vote no on House Bill 1102 the
bill that criminalizes selling an animal
with any birth deformity that causes
suffering and cites brais Val as an
example brochis Val is not formally
defined in state law or veterinary
medicine and this leaves a lot of room
for inconsistent and subjective
interpretation this also makes the bill
unenforceable which I know we've talked
about today due to conflicting
interpretations that may
arise this bill is also it's an attack
on breeders pet stores and pet owners as
short muzzled dogs has been bred for
thousands of years we know in fact that
the four of the most popular dog breeds
of 2022 could be classified as braches
phallic including number one which was
the French
Bulldog there are also beloved and
popular brais cat breeds including the
Burmese Himalayan and Persian as well so
because of this we know that if this
bill passes demand for these animals
will not go down and instead this will
force Granite Staters to go out of state
or online to obtain these popular
animals as you've heard today the degree
of brais falic traits can vary um
responsible breeders uh they avoid
producing animals with Boaz as you've
heard before from some of the Breeders
that have testified and this is
mitigated through careful stewardship
and public education we know that
responsible breeders are Health testing
their animals they're also educating the
families that purchase these animals on
any issues that can arise or any special
care that they need so we believe at the
pet advocacy Network that the health of
an animal is a conversation between an
owner and their veterinarian because of
that we ask you today to vote no on
House Bill 1102 and instead work with us
to find effective ways to promote animal
welfare in New Hampshire thank
you thank you ma'am do we have any
questions from committee representative
Geron
sir thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I just thinking about
the pointing out that you know we're
talking about the four most popular
breeds on some level doesn't that make
legislation like this a little bit more
meaningful in the sense that and I I
hear we're going to hear testimony over
and over and over again about
responsible breeders I think I hope
we're all on the same page about that
but the popularity of these animals also
increases the likelihood of breeders who
are not responsible who are meeting a
market demand and it it also means that
popularity means that we likely to see a
lot of people who are wanting to
purchase these animals because of the
aesthetic of it which again it leads
toward breeding animals with shorter
features so um do you think that the
fact that they are more and more
popular could in fact lead to more and
more animals being bred for a market
that suffer from some for example Boaz
so I think that any breed is susceptible
to health issues I think you've heard
about some cancers in German or golden
retrievers hip dysplasia and German
Shepherds but I think I think what's
important here is that these breeds
although popular that bralic does not
equate to unhealthy you have heard about
Boaz which can be an issue that arises
in these breeds but our view on that is
that that is something a veterinarian
should address not
legislation um and again these breeds
are very popular and they're also very
expensive when you're getting them from
breeders so as was pointed out before
people who are paying this much money
for an animal are doing their research
about the healthy issues that can arise
and having those conversations with fets
as
well thank you thank you for your
question I do have a question and it's
similar to one I asked a minute because
I'm just trying to come to grips with it
as you read
this um proposed
legislation in your mind does this
legislation indicate that you will not
or cannot legally breed these animals so
that that's how I'm reading it um again
it is fairly vague so and I think it
leads to subjective interpretation which
is part of the issue that people can
interpret this multiple ways again
that's going to make it really hard to
enforce and so you do not differentiate
the difference between a pug for
example without deformity that causes
suffering versus a pug that has
deformity or suffering I don't think
this bill specifies Boaz is if I think
that's what you're asking me I don't
think it's speaking directly to these
animals that have breathing issues I
think it's encompassing them as a whole
um I do think that that's something that
could be split out but again I don't
think that that would have
enforceability as well and therefore
should just be left up to pet owners and
their vets okay thank you thank you any
other questions
okay thank you so much thank you and if
please good afternoon Vice chair and
members of the committee my name is
Ashley Monty and I'm here on behalf of
people for the ethical treatment of
animals and are more than 31,000 members
and supporters in New Hampshire to
express our support of House Bill
1102 with breeders turning out more
congenitally unhealthy dogs than ever we
are in urgent need of legislation to
protect animals from being intentionally
bred to have deformities like braisy
which causes them a lifetime of
suffering brais spelic animals like
French bulldogs English Bulldogs pugs
and Persian cats are bred to have
extremely abnormal and shortened muzzles
small skulls and and deformed bodies
there's overwhelming scientific evidence
confirming that as a result of being
bred to have unnaturally flat faces many
of these brais phalic breeds suffer from
terrible discomfort pain debilitating
health issues including a condition
called bralic obstructive Airway
syndrome which causes them to struggle
just to breathe and is actually the
leading cause of death for
Bulldogs research confirms that these
flat-faced breathing impaired dogs have
a significant shorter life expectancy
than other breeds and are more likely to
suffer from spinal and esophagal
diseases cornal ulcerative disease and
painful dental
disease veterinarians around the world
are sounding the alarm on the problems
with these breeds and a number of
countries including Austria Germany the
Netherlands and Norway now restrict or
prohibit their breeding which they refer
to as torture
breeding that's because purely for the
purpose of achieving a flat-faced look
these breeds have been bred so that
their snouts are shortened and pushed so
far back against their skulls and there
isn't enough space to accommodate their
normal anatomical features causing them
immense pain and
suffering breathing impaired breeds
typically spend their lives struggling
to breathe and many of them can't even
enjoy the basic activities that make a
dog's life enjoyable and fulfilling like
going for a walk chasing a ball or
playing with other dogs these animals
spend their entire existence just trying
to get enough air in their lungs anyone
who has spent time with one of these
dogs has likely heard them rasping and
wheezing and those are the sounds of an
animal struggling to breathe by
supporting House Bill 112 which would
ban this cruel practice of purposefully
breeding chronically unhealthy breathing
impaired breeds the committee will help
protect vulnerable dogs and cats who now
more than ever desperately need our help
thank you for your consideration thank
you ma'am and representative kto thank
you Mr chair could I get a copy of your
testimony please thank you if you could
pass that up are there any further
questions representative Bixby so uh do
you have any experience in uh uh cruel
animal cruelty investigations in New
Hampshire I do not this is actually not
my specific area of expertise I'm here
just to present peta's position on the
bill
yeah okay thank you so much appreciate
your testimony absolutely
Alber good afternoon thank you for
hearing me uh my name is Donna Alber I
live in Lowden and I strongly oppose
House Bill
1102 and for my I I got to shorten
everything up here with three
minutes um first I want to say that
there are no breeders or anybody in this
room that I feel wants to contribute to
animal suffering we are not going to
purposely put a pink and blue dog
together because it's going to make
purple and that's what people want um I
am now with uh Boston Terriers and I'm
also speaking on behalf of the Boston
Terrier Club of America for this
uh for just kind of a brief history I
was raised in the dog show world my
parents bred basset hounds my father was
an AKC judge I did the whole Junior
handling thing went to Westminster so I
understand the confirmation breeding and
again in my retirement I fell in love
with Boston's and now I'm back at
showing again I'm going to Westminster
this year I want to breed and I have two
that I would like to breed
come the fall um so anyway to get back
to that but also my education is in the
animal um Veterinary field I've worked
in animal
hospitals since I was 15 years old till
I retired I managed an emergency clinic
in Manchester for two years prior to
moving to Lowden and I have to say in
all of those years experience I have
never seen hardly any I really honestly
can't remember any cases coming in with
dogs struggling to breathe because of
being a brachy spalc breed there's other
factors the dog can be overweight the
dog could have other health issues it
could have allergies it could live in a
household where there's chimney smokers
smoking inside okay um one thing I do
want to bring out um I do all the health
testing that is required with a one
results I learned about an hsf4 Gene
that causes juvenile cataracts my dogs
do not carry the gene they will not pass
that along because that would cause a
dog to go blind by the time it is two
years old and that is certainly not
something I'm going to do I had in here
from the Boston terer Club of
America um the required list of tests I
can give copy of this out and they you
go on a chick registry which is an
online registry to show that you have
done all the testing and people can look
that up okay thank you you got 15
seconds 15 seconds all right let me look
in one second here um Boston Terriers
excel in all performance Sports and it
has been classed uh clocked in at 26.9 6
miles an hour for one of them doing a
fast cat run without having problems
breathing okay they do dis dog dock
diving type thing
um fast cat The Obedience things they
they don't have a problem breathing so I
think the
classify and group all these breeds into
one dish is is wrong thank you ma'am
appreciate your testimony any questions
from the committee several
representative H
Haskins thank you thank you for taking
my question I have a grand dog who's a
Boston
Terrier um so I'm struggling I thought
when I came into this committee room
today I knew exactly how I'd vote on
this bill but Penny's story has turned
me inside
out um even though you haven't
encountered these problems you don't
disagree that they exist in other dogs
they could possibly exist in some other
dogs there could be other like I said
other health issues that are adding
to the you know having breathing issues
um it sounds like there were other
health issues going on because I don't
know of any breathing disorder that's
going to require blood transfusion so I
think there was some other health issues
going on but again I don't know you know
I feel horrible for her to have gone
through that and yes I have health
insurance on my dogs but I will say one
thing I've had one pug in my life which
never had an issue breathing but I was
concerned because we do a lot of camping
and I'm thinking oh my gosh if we're way
up North or whatever dog stung his
throat swelling up I bought an endot
tral tube and that stays with me all the
time I have never had to use on the Pug
I never had to use it on my other
dogs follow if I may yes
ma'am do you know whether Insurance pet
insurance with which my son has on his
puppy
MH is um can you have insurance
against a breed just because he's that
breed and has perhaps a breathing
problem are you saying not able to
obtain insur insurance or will the
insurance well whether yeah whether the
insurance would cover um something
that's uh just a manifestation of the
breed I'm struggling you know to know
how that would work are there are as
many health insurance policies out there
than there are St in the sky SAR sure um
but as long as my understanding would be
if it's a not a you know pre-existing
condition there's the point then I would
sure I would be confident saying it
would be covered but again every
policies are different thank you thank
you manam representative K do you have a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking on my question could you
uh can I get a copy of that literature
for the files please absolutely thank
you than
you any further
questions thank you so much for your
testimony thank you for if I could call
gon
good afternoon everyone my name is Joel
gon I live up in Hillsboro I came here
today to speak in support of this
legislation Banning the breeding of
intentionally deformed animals like
flatface breathing impaired breeds would
protect countless dogs and cats who are
currently forced to endure a lifetime of
chronic and painful
ailments these animals can suffer
immensely because breeders purposefully
select for unhealthy traits in an effort
to make these animals more aesthetically
pleasing to
us these intentionally deformed animals
are prone to Chronic respiratory issues
due to their narrowed nostrils or uh
distorted wind pipes uh and they also
suffer from dental problems because
their teeth are
overcrowded because they're struggling
to breathe they can't properly Thermo
regulate which puts them a greater risk
of heat stroke um and heat stress
additionally their excessive wrinkles uh
often lead to painful skin infections as
mentioned earlier uh the shape of their
skulls that's what causes their eyes to
bulge um that can lead to a flat-faced
dog suffering from corneal ulcers and
that's uh common at very high rates uh
because of their narrow hips and
unnaturally large heads Approximately
80% of Bulldogs are bred using
artificial insemination and delivered
via
C-sections uh we cannot allow people to
continue breeding animals who we
know uh could live in a state of
constant pain and discomfort as they
struggle to breathe and carry out other
basic tasks um I would have to imagine
everyone here uh has experience with an
animal companion or has been around dogs
and cats so uh I don't have to argue the
point about how amazing these animals
are um and our Animal Companions dogs
and cats they have almost complete trust
in
us uh we owe it to them to protect them
from this exploitation and abuse uh we
need to ban on these cruel breeding
practices now
thank you very much for your time thank
you sir represent compto thank you Mr
chair could I get your
testimony sure thank you are there any
further
questions thank you sir I appreciate
your
please
hi there I am Andrea Hans I live in
effing New Hampshire thank you madam
chairman and the environment and
agricultural committee I um appreciate
living in New Hampshire where citizens
can have the opportunity such is this to
voice opinions on the potential laws of
the state um I was going to read the
rest of my testimony but I'd like to
I've passed out um letters from CFA and
Tika they are the two
largest cat Registries cat genetic
Registries in the world and it talks
about how um the standards are
determined if you look on page three at
the bottom of the Tikka letter it says
and I'll read it Breaky saal refers only
to the shape of the head and the ratio
of the short length to longer distances
of the head width it is just a
description of the heads of certain
breeds of animals and can appear both
pathologically or non-pathological as a
result of normal variation in SC skull
shape it is not by itself a birth
deformity prior to the accept acceptance
of any Breed by Tikka the genetics
committee reviews the
standard and researches possible Health
consequences of accepting that breed
indeed in keeping with the Health and
Welfare of its breeds the tika breed
standards actually penalize bite defects
and inability to breathe breathing
problems are checked by knowledgeable
and experienced judges by
characteristics like the size of the
nostrils their weight and the position
of the nose line not the Breaky saali
itself so that's part of the purpose of
why we have Cat shows is so that the
judge can go over breeding stock and
individuals at Cat shows um you can show
a um a neutered pet which is probably
produced by a breeder so you can also
see animals that are not kept for
breeding purposes and how they conform
to the
standard
um many braiders expend much time
resources and funds to contribute to the
research which will better the life of
the breeding stock and progyny of their
chosen breed the PKD test for Persians
has greatly reduced the incidence of
polycystic kidney disease in the Persian
population parent cats that test C clear
cannot reproduce off offspring that
would be
afflicted it is difficult to understand
that what is the actual current problem
that this bill is trying to address in
New Hampshire the bill seems unspecific
vague and open-ended while at the same
time highly
punitive um I do have a concern that the
message that this bill sends is that
there is zero tolerance in New Hampshire
for disabled pets in general under house
bill 1102 to transfer a disabled pet is
an act of Cruelty for the person looking
to transfer regardless of the condition
of the pet or whether or not it can live
comfortably in a New Hampshire home with
Proper Care thank you so much for
hearing my testimony I oppose
um House Bill
1102 thank you any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony this
afternoon um I call Robert
speak good afternoon welcome to
environment and agriculture good
afternoon good to be here thank you
chairman eron committee members um I'm
Robert Miller Brentwood New Hampshire
resident I'm a dog owner cat owner too
um but dogs I train them breed them um
and hunt them um I'm strongly opposed to
HB 1102 um and I'm going to kind of take
a little different route here um what
really this is is nothing more than an
attempt by animal rights activists to
restrict our abilities and our our right
to choose the animal that we want
um
that's kind of just the hook
that's being hung on the brais saali and
cruelty and all that um as you you were
told and as you're aware that um this is
the first time this legislation has been
introduced in any state in the United
States um this is a test case and they
will take the language and the comments
that are made here and there and tweak
it and it will show up elsewhere um
that's just kind of how things go with
um with these things um but do we really
want New Hampshire to be the guinea pig
for animal rights policy um I don't as a
resident I'm kind of outraged by that um
and you know how ridiculous to create a
felony for breeding dogs or cats um as
this bill would do the second offense
becomes a felony um and I know we're
going to hear from some veterinarians
here in um an esteemed V from the United
Kingdom but do we want
to take our
cues from 3,000 miles away on how we
should set Animal Welfare policy in this
state I don't I don't think so
um I think it's a little arrogant and
presumptuous that other jurisdictions
that have done this um somehow are more
enlightened than we are um I kind of
find that offensive um and not to forget
that the last time
the British uh try to impo impose their
their will on us we had a tea party in
Boston Harbor and then a revolution um
Live Free or Die um Freedom also means
being able to choose the animal that you
want thank you that's it any questions
for representative ger thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question sure so I just wanted Devil's
Advocate uh let's take the most extreme
situation somebody has to two dogs which
are clearly suffering from boas right
but they are aesthetically pleasing to
the breed they breed those two dogs
because the result will be an aesthetic
presumably an aesthetically pleasing
animal that they can sell for
profit is is this a case in your mind
should any should we be able to do
anything to prevent that worst case
scenario perhaps we should but I don't
believe this bill will do that okay
thank
you any other questions from the
committee representative ktoa thank you
madam chair oh thank you madam chair uh
thank you for your testimony uh do you
have copies of your testimony I do thank
you could pass him around Madam chair
point of personal privilege the chair
said at the beginning of the hearing
that no one is on people's motives I can
guarantee you and I have email evidence
that I put this in of my bition with my
own thought and I was not contacted by
any animal rights organization until
well after the the bill was introduced
into the house so that was not gabbled
out of order when this person who I've
never met before said that I made a
presumption that I had put in a bill
because the organization I I don't
believe he mentioned your name or the
sponsor Prime spor and he said that I
put it in because of animal
organizations that is not all right
Point well taken thank
you um I call Stacy
speak good afternoon chair Ain members
of the committee my name is Stacy oer I
am the New England government relations
manager for the the American Kennel Club
and I am here to oppose House Bill 1102
thank you for the opportunity to speak
with you all this afternoon I also want
to take a moment and publicly thank the
dog breeders and dog lovers behind me
who have taken time from work um family
obligations and other commitments to be
here this afternoon to be certain that
you all have accurate information and a
resource to ask these questions of those
who are breeding dogs
I do want to note that I take exception
to statements that have been made that
breed Registries are encouraging and
breeders are chasing extreme
confirmation that is a
mischaracterization of the American
Kennel Club so I want to take a moment
to do a little bit of a dive on who is
the American Kennel Club what do we do
and whether or not um New Hampshire has
a problem with pet related
suffering um I have shared for instance
with you all uh I had asked the parent
clubs of some of the brachy calic breeds
to in fact submit a statement to the
committee to help educate the committee
about their breed standard and um it's
really the Bible that they use in order
to ensure that their breeding programs
are being undertaken responsibly for the
purpose of not only preserving breed
characteristics and producing healthy
Wells socialized purebred puppies but
our Affiliated clubs I've know I've
shared with you that AKC is a club of
clubs and we have more than 200
Affiliated parent clubs that are
responsible for the individual
recognized breeds uh so the second
handout that's going
around is a um public education tool
that we use to help the public
understand more about the breeds when
you open it up it has all the recognized
AKC breed as the centerfold so it's one
example of the public education um that
we engage in um to ensure that the
public has the right information and
choosing the right pet for them the
parent clubs actually develop and
approve the preds official standard
which is a written description of the
ideal specimen of their Breed by
describing its structure temperament and
instincts on rare occasion the club may
make revisions so I wanted to for the
record clarify that in fact
breed parent clubs it's not the breed
registry AKC is the largest purebred dog
registry that maintains a registry but
it is the parent club that owns the
standard for their breed and it is rare
that they will change the standard in
the packet that I uh distributed to you
all for instance I'd really appreciate
you turning to halfway through is a
statement from the Bulldog Club of
America for instance and they have
provided the committee with an update
with regard to their standard was
adopted in
1896 they it was amended in
1976 in 1990 reformatted to conform uh
description of the gate was moved from
the beginning to the end so a technical
change and in 2016 it was amended eight
years ago to add a disqualification for
certain um colors and what we know is
that certain colors or genetic
introduction into Purebread bulldogs for
example can introduce health problems um
for instance the meral color can
contribute to deafness for instance so
that would be the reason it would be a
health rated reason as to why the parent
club would actually make a change to
their breed
standard AKC strongly opposes the
breeding of dogs by those who would do
so without regard for the animals
welfare and I wanted to mention all of
the things that AKC does to stand up for
dogs we have an online Canan College to
teach responsible breeding with
practical step-by-step approaches by
joining one of our clubs breeders learn
about the Health and Welfare topics and
they get mentored and share experience
by others in the breed the K9 Health
Foundation is funded by our clubs and
has uh provided more than 68 million in
can9 health research that benefits all
dogs and we applaud the efforts of all
the scientists and veterinarians who
continue to work to Advanced can9 Health
research and education this is a
developmental process and uh Improvement
and progress but never is there
Perfection I will acknowledge that um we
also have a breeder of Merit program
that recognizes breeders who certify
that their breeding stock has been
tested in accordance with the parent
club's guidelines we support future
veterinarian study in the oenology which
is the branch of veterinary medicine
concerned with obstetrics physiology and
diseases of animal reproductive systems
why is that in my testimony you'll see
that it is rare that a uh School of
veterinary medicine actually includes
and requires the study of small animal
theog genology
um last in terms of what the scope of
the problem is I have submitted to the
committee I did a public information
request with the New Hampshire Attorney
General's office and asked for all of
the pet related complaints over the last
three years and I've given a brief uh
summary of the results there were four
online scams from January 1st 2021 to
January 1st
2024 those were infectious disease or
individuals who made payments online and
never received a pet one cat breeder I
think um your your time is is over
um I uh I want to know if there's any uh
questions from the committee
representative
Penza can I have her finish that because
I think it's the you only have a couple
more just summarizing I just want to
hear what statistics yes just okay sure
would you uh please thank you for the
question representative let us know that
yes and I'll just be brief U there were
four online scams I know we've talked
about that in this committee before
there was one New Hampshire cat breeder
that uh sold a maincoon cat
that was diagnosed with a viral
infection and they got a replacement
animal um that also be had an infectious
disease uh there are four complaints get
against New Hampshire pet stores and
there was one New Hampshire dog breeder
uh individual bought two French Bulldogs
the complaint said the seller was
without a New Hampshire license and had
a criminal record and one of the dogs
was diagnosed with a congenital heart
condition so I wanted the committee to
know that of all the data from the New
Hampshire Attorney General's office the
department of Justice on consumer
protection those were the um all of the
complaints that had been submitted under
the Consumer Protection Law here in New
Hampshire none of them refer to
respiratory suffering or um ailments
here in New Hampshire uh so I hope
that's helpful to the committee so so
what you're saying is that um there has
not been anybody who's bought a Frenchie
or Shih Tzu or um a boxer that has had
uh any kind of problems as a result of
uh of its breed or breeder that has made
a complaint to the New Hampshire
Attorney General's office just the one
that I mentioned um you know because you
heard earlier that lot people spend a
lot of money on pets these days if there
had been issues I think it's likely that
people would pursue action through the
consumer under the consumer protection
laws which is why I requested the data
I've heard the committee often ask if
anyone has the data on a particular
problem that a bill is trying to solve
so I I did submit a freedom of
information
request okay so you're suggesting that
there is no problem with this kind of
breeding uh going on in New Hampshire
I'm saying the data from the Attorney
General's office suggests that there is
not correction okay any other representa
kraton thank you madam chair and thank
you for your testimony and I I
appreciate you consolidating all of your
sub club's information and input I
haven't read it uh in your knowledge in
these standards by all of your sub 200
sub
clubs uh is there anything
prohibiting the the breeding of animals
that are suffering in in some way all of
these clubs have ethical requirements to
be a member of the club so yes and let's
not forget the uh members of these clubs
you know I'd like to say that
veterinarians have knowledge about
animals that is a mile wide the members
of these parent clubs have knowledge
about their particular breed that is a
mile deep in terms of the genetics
they're studying pedigrees um they're
funding the genetic research that you
heard earlier to ensure that they can
improve upon the breed they are
preservation breeders they have invested
their time money commitment passion um
in producing healthy dogs that that's
who these parent club members are so I
appreciate the opportunity to correct
the record in that regard okay thank you
representative
Penza so kind of piggybacking on what
representative kraton said um based upon
the all the Breeders that you have um
would you you said in the in your
testimony that there's a certain
character it would be like color that
would show if if it's deviating from the
breed that would then impact other
health explain that because you're
saying just literally like a marking
could show that okay well that could
then cause other different types of
deformity sure in the packet for
instance probably at the end because I
believe they're alphabetical um the
panes Club of America for instance that
breed has been around for a thousand
years and they're communicating to the
committee when I reviewed their
statement that at this point they don't
they have one of the healthiest breeds
because um they have not introduced
other breeds or factors into the
pedigree and therefore they have over
time been able to eliminate health
issues altogether so there can be bad
actors who will promote publicly for
instance um and it would be I think a
buyer beware sign if you saw someone
that was marketing rare or exotic color
Bulldog um or a designer breed typically
that means this is someone that is not
breeding to the standard they are uh
selling you know uh basically something
that is not a pure bread but they're
hoping to get additional money by virtue
of calling it exotic or rare colored or
or things of this nature and that's
essentially what they've done is created
a mixed breed dog um and so you know
even when you look for instance at the
bulldog Club of America they've provided
for you two pictures one of what
Bulldogs looked like um back in the
1800s and what they look like today in
confirmation with the breed standard of
the Bulldog Club of America so they
they've provided pictures with you for
you as well as to what a bulldog looks
like follow up
followup so um these you know let's say
Bad actors that are designer the things
that you just said would not be
incorporated into your Association
correct cor that's correct they likely
licensed at they if they're following
New Hampshire laws because you have to
have a health certificate to transfer an
animal and whatnot um but there's fraud
out there as there is in other
Industries so I'm just acknowledging
that um as an a thing that exists so
would you say that the position of your
organization because I think the most
compelling thing out of the testimony
from the sponsor is this picture in the
back here about um you know you have one
picture of the dog that's literally got
no face and then one that has like would
you say that um the position of your
organization is to not be cutting things
short in that would would you say that
you guys are are going towards more of
what things look like maybe you know 50
years ago what I'm trying to say is that
the breed standards have not recently
changed to accommodate cuteness or
appearance we have been committed and
invested in uh preserving these breeds
for generations and ensuring their
health by funding the research and and
all the rest so I haven't been privy to
the picture that you've been shown but I
am encouraging you to look at the
Bulldog Club of America's pictures
because earlier the statement was made
that for instance Bulldogs now have
shorter legs or whatnot so I'm I'm just
acknowledging there are pictures there
for you from Bulldogs a 100 years ago
and what they look like
today okay yeah thank
you any other questions from the
committee of Representative Howard thank
you madam chair just a quick follow up
on representative sure go ahead um so um
I'll describe this to you so so this
this dog on the left has a very flat
face this one has a a very prominent
muzzle um does that mean that one of
these would be rejected from your club
because it because it doesn't match the
picture in the blue flyer that you sent
us what a judge is doing is
evaluating those dogs in the ring and
how closely they conform to the ideal
standard that is described in the parent
breed club's standard description I
think you would be hardpressed to find a
standard that says that it should have a
flattened nose or recently changed to
say these extreme charact appearan are
what's being sought I think that's a
mischaracterization and misinforms the
kitty the committee in making that type
of
statement there are different lengths of
muzzle within one breed as well I think
that's to be acknowledged uh for sure
representative Bixby yeah do you have
any any familiarity with uh the
procedures for cruelty investigations in
New
Hampshire I know someone here that does
so I'll wait and let them speak to it as
an expert in that regard but I do
appreciate the question representative
thank you thank
you any other questions from the
committee thank you for your testimony
it all right um I call
um Joyce oves I'm sorry if I
name
I didn't plan on speaking hello
um I was more interested I came with an
open mind because I could not
understand how anything I have been
doing for almost 40 years could be
considered cruel I'm a pug
breeder I read 37 litter and 106
puppies but backing up before I even
bred
pug went neck to neck with my Irish
Setter kept up doing
everything I called them Peak Baggers
they went Mountain
hiking we went snow shooting
uh CrossCountry skiing everything pugs
did
and then I got into pug breeding and um
it's been a really learning experience
no litter that I have bred has been
alike they've all been different every
pug I've
bred has its own
personality um I have never had a pug
with a breathing
issue um so that it affected its quality
of life
um to me a Pug was a perfect allaround
dog um I used it in
therapy I would bring it to the nursing
homes twice a week um it was the perfect
animal to the size
to sit on a a senior lab
um it just boggles my
considered cruelty it's like
wow
um so many things
were brought up to point when she
presented this bill
like I get health certificates for every
litter and when I adopt my
puppies they have to um go through a a
really
long
process
um educating the the
buyer and I always make
them is that I'm done with oh okay
they have to take any puppy that they
adopt to a vet of their
choice so they have two vet
visits and there are certain items like
luxating Pella that is
subjective of one vet could find fine
but the next vet you know within two
days can say well you have a little a
different grade of luxating
patella
um
sorry thank you for listening thank you
thank you for your testimony we
appreciate what you have to say um any
questions for the from the
committee seeing none thank you so much
for coming today and and uh sharing your
lobe
good afternoon my name is Pam lob I'm
here today uh representing the American
Brussels Griffon Association I am
fortunate to live in Vermont and was
able to come over to represent my
organization um these are my Brussels
Griffons um so I have a written
statement which I submitted and uh I
also submitted a copy of the parent Club
position statement which is also in the
packet that Stacy submitted so um you've
got multiple copies of it and I would
like to read my statement but I would
also like to address some of the
comments that I've heard earlier today
and some of the statements other people
have made so I'm going to digress from
my written statement a little bit here
since you've all got a copy of that um
one of the highlights of my written
statement though is something that I
learned when I lived in Maryland and we
had a breed ban in our state and what I
learned is if you legislate against
something like dogs that people want to
own people just go underground I will
tell you that in 1997 we enacted a breed
band against pitbulls this it is one of
the few places in the nation that the
ban is still on the books and the number
of pitbulls in that county has not been
decreased at all I can tell you that
because I sat on the commission for
animal control in my County I
adjudicated those cases so legislation
doesn't necessarily we can't legislate
morality um so the legislation may or
may not change what breeders do they may
just go underground they'll stop getting
dog licenses because they don't want a
legal record of the fact that they own
these breeds
um so that becomes a concern um another
concern that um was brought up that um
I'm I've listened to the comments and
that sort of thing um there was a
question about genetics and about color
um brachy has nothing to do with the
color of a dog but the reason some of
our breed standards uh list certain
acceptable colors and certain colors not
acceptable to answer your question
earlier there are certain issues in
genetics with dilute genes so if you
have a black dog and you have a sort of
a gray colored dog in dogs most of us
call that gray color blue so if you've
heard of blue dogs um there is a
dilution Gene that causes the black to
dilute and become blue and in many
breeds not all but in many breeds
there's something called color dilution
alopecia and you can Google that and uh
it means that blue dogs and dilute brown
dogs sort of the cream color dogs um can
lose their hair there's a video that
went around last year of a border
colleague running at CRTs running
agility beautiful run the dog's back is
completely balded that dog was blue and
white he was very athletic he could
still run but he had no hair I am not a
breeder I'm an owner of dogs I represent
a a parent Club but as a breeder if I
had a dog that had alipa I wouldn't be
breeding that dog um okay uh by the same
nature my breed is you've got videos
that were submitted of my breed running
agility my breed running fast cat my own
dog is in the AKC book of the dog doing
obedience um he's got a dumbbell in his
mouth and he's clearing a jump he's got
as flat a face as they come but he did
scent discrimination he did the retrieve
he did all of those things so there are
I've flown my dogs annually to
Louisville entucky to my National
Specialty flat-faced dog I can fly him
braisy is just a descriptive term um
that's you know again it's not all in my
written statement but those are some of
the questions people had um the
C-section question my dogs were born
naturally they were weled naturally I
know a lot of women who schedule
C-sections as to have it on their
convenience rather than giving birth at
2 o'clock in the morning when their
OBGYN may not be available it happens in
people too it's not just dogs so I thank
you all very much for your time and for
allowing an out of stator to come and
testify happy to answer any question
absolutely um so again the term
brai does not necessarily mean unhealthy
correct and it does not necessarily mean
the dog is suffering correct or cat
whatever I did medical transcription for
20 years and it's a word in dorland's
medical dictionary it's a descriptive
word there's there's another word for
longf Coles there's a word that
describes that do you consider that a
birth defect absolutely not okay thank
you any other question represented
Penza so I'm G to try to pronounce it
braas wow okay so that um so would you
consider that like let's say if we're
comparing that to a human so I had my
nose broken three times I had a DV
symptom I could still breathe so are you
considering that kind of like the same
thing well braie SE y just means
flat-faced or flath headed it doesn't
really describe ability to breathe it
doesn't describe any um physiological
abilities it's it's a descriptive it's
like saying this table is flat okay it
doesn't address whether this is a sturdy
table or whether this is a functional
table it just means that this table is
flat and the dog's face is flattened or
head is flattened now brachy calic
breeds can be Cavalier ch King Charles
Spaniels they have faces um Chows are
considered braches spalc they have noses
um there are a number of breeds that
fall under the characteristic
Rottweilers
Boxers um they have length of muzzle but
it's a shortened length of muzzle it
doesn't describe it as being ineffective
or inefficient just that it's flatter
it's just again it's just a descriptive
terminology word
represent Gera thank you madam chair
thank you for taking my question so I I
think we've heard a lot of testimony and
strong sense that using brachy is is not
the appropriate way uh to to just you
know approach this issue because it's
it's a phenotype not a genotype Etc um
so I'll ask you the same question I
asked somebody else earlier does it make
sense would this bill be better if it
focused on boas which is a syndrome
right so by definition again it's a
pathological condition
uh rather than what I think we should
all at this point have reached the
conclusion that the descriptor is not
what we should be concentrating on here
but rather the condition well I can say
that the
concept of finding a condition like that
to
be illegal by definition it becomes
illegal um is an interesting
concept but how are we enforcing this is
somebody going to knock on every door of
every dog breeder and check on this is
every puppy going to have to be seen and
certified by a vet as free of this and
if you do find that somebody has
produced uh braches spalc obstructive
Airway syndrome um are we are we
imprisoning this person are we disposing
of these dogs we had a term in Prince
George's County Maryland we're going to
dispose of the dogs according to law and
that mean we were putting the dog to
sleep we were euthanizing that animal
that was disposed of according to law is
that what's going to happen to these
brachy pallic animals or these dogs with
you know obstructive Airway disorder
what what is I understand that the
sponsor um is trying to protect people
from having to live with sick animals
nobody wants to live with a sick animal
um it's pretty miserable living a dog
with skin allergies I don't want to
produce dogs with skin skin allergies
but I don't think that we can legislate
that because there are degrees and I
think that ultimately we're talking
about living creatures and What Becomes
of those living creatures that are now
in violation of this
law thank
you any other questions thank you very
much for your testimony this afternoon
thank you for having you I'd like to
chelini
thank you hi good afternoon good
afternoon uh thank you for having me my
name is Dr James chelini I've been a
board-certified Veterinary neurologist
and neurosurgeon for about seven years
and a veterinarian since 2009 I'm
currently licensed in Rhode Island and
overall I am in support of Bill HB 1102
because is my professional and personal
belief that Brey seili is the worst
burden ever placed upon companion
animals it would be very easy for me to
Simply provide many examples of Brey
spelic dog suffering that I've witnessed
throughout my career just this last week
I performed spinal surgery on three
French bulldogs I currently work at a
very large 247 ER and Specialty Center
in Rhode Island and I've spent my career
working only in facilities such as this
across the country during my various
stages of training it would also be easy
for me to Simply state that I've never
met a specialist or an emergency vet
that doesn't share my view in relation
to break SE which is that break sey is
by and large not in the best interest of
the animal and leads to a tremendous
amount of morbidity and mortality the
problem though with simply show showing
cases of these dogs suffering is that
those who support the creation of Breaky
calic pets such as breeders can simply
always default to a common argument
which is that only poorly bred bralic
dogs suffer by Shifting the blame onto
backyard breeders or unethical breeders
terms which have no real consistent
definition Breaky calic dog and cat
breeders are able to absolve themselves
from the truth of the matter which is
that Breaky SEI is intentional malformed
Anatomy that greatly reduces the quality
of life of a significant portion of
those dogs that suffer from it I'd like
to reference the breed standards from
four the more popular dog breeds
according to the AKC the Frenchie the
English Bulldog the Boston teror and the
Pug the breed clubs of all four of these
breeds describe a breed standard that
calls for severe
brachy in the French Bulldog they list a
extremely short nose the English bulldog
lists extremely short face and muzzle
and the Boston interior literally shows
a correct more braic example versus an
incorrect less brachy calic example they
have it backwards they're likely going
to be many who oppose this bill while
using the argument that not all brachy
calic animals suffer many dog owners and
breed enthusiasts like to show their
dogs running agility training and being
very active in general as evidence that
being braak calic doesn't necessarily
mean your suffering this completely
misses the point first of all research
has shown that by and large the public
does not recognize many of the sympt of
distress that these breeds show and
they're in fact encouraged as some sort
of quirky behavior in inherent to the
breed refering I'm referring to snorting
snoring and overall loud breathing
considered normal for these breeds
secondly no one on my side of the
argument to my knowledge is arguing that
100% of brachy calic dogs are miserable
and in pain 247 the fact of the matter
is that when you strive to create a dog
whose breed standard is an anatomical
malformation you may manage to create
many dogs who overcome their disability
at appear outwardly happy and healthy
but you will also create many dogs who
suffer a lifetime of difficulty
breathing chronic pain and immobility it
is both the pursuit of a faulty standard
and the standard itself that should
either change or stop in my
opinion I'd like to also address the
notion if I may that there is no
evidence to support braisy being
inherently bad for an animals Health I'd
like to refer anyone interested in
researching this to a website called
PubMed where you can type in the words
Breaky seil dog and immediately have
access to dozens of research AR articles
investigating
brachy I would also like to point out
that the term brachy spalc obstructive
Airway syndrome or Boaz for short starts
with the word brachy calic it is
essentially exclusive to these dogs with
that confirmation the breed standards
are the disease I could go on and on
about how Breaky seil and boxers Boston
Terriers and Bulldogs has linked to a
much higher risk of malignant brain
cancer I could also go on about the
spinal malformations that are literally
built into French and English bulldogs
and Boston teriors thanks to the
disheveled 2 genetic variant or how
French Bulldogs frequently die from a
herniated disc or the horrific skull
morphologies of Persian cats or the fact
that Breaky Violet dogs have
significantly shorter lifespans and are
four times more expensive to ensure for
their pet owners okay your time is up
sir and can we have a copy of your
testimony do you have you want to know
yeah sure are there representative Bixby
we have questions also to you for
you
thank
you yeah so um I was wondering if uh
brechos phallic breeds tend to uh
exhibit higher levels of
corticosteroids higher I don't know okay
because which corticosteroids are of
course a a stress one so okay are you
you're aware of that right of what a
cortical steroid it is yes yes yes and
that and that they are they're
associated with higher levels of stress
okay thank
you representative
Penza so my question is about the
insurance piece because um someone spoke
about that earlier uh we got a lot of
testimony of course pro and con in in
regards with this and um pretty pretty
much I I know this from a friend of mine
that uh they had pet insurance and they
had to spend about I don't know
$7,000 um out of pocket that was some
was covered by insurance for their um
surgery that happened to their pug but
um so can you speak to that just a
little bit about um because pet
insurance should be a given especially
when you're spending a lot of money on a
dog so where yeah so um I cited that uh
data from a paper study uh published in
the vet record journal in
2020 um I think the bigger issue are you
asking like should owners just be aware
of pet insurance for these own just like
the there automatically pet insurance is
not covering you know they're not
covering for these surgeries or they're
considered I'm hearing that more and
more from clients because the pet
insurance companies are getting wise to
the fact that they are having to Shell
out five figure reimbursements to people
for these pets and they are thus hiking
their premiums in the first place if you
look on any uh pet insurance premium
aggregate website you'll see that these
animals have the highest premiums way
disproportional to their size um and a
lot of pet insurance companies are no
longer covering things because they
happen so frequently in these dogs
they're just viewing them as inherent
parts of the dog more or less and so
they're declining
coverage
okay oh H Haskins rep representative
Haskins I'm sorry thank you madam chair
and thank you for taking my question do
you have access to information that
would help us determine why this is
controversial among um animal breeders
who obviously love their animals and
some have studied their breed and yet
there's a contradiction here at hand
that we have to deal with as to whether
or not brachio is actually a deformity
could you speak to that at all um as far
like why why breeders are hesitant to
why is it a deformity in your view when
it's just
a um well okay so for one it I'm not
aware of any instance in nature where
Brak SE just pops up and it's part
of an animal's being I mean where do you
see this you know anywhere um there may
be some example somewhere but the facts
remains that this has been artificially
selected for decades if not maybe like a
couple hundred thousands of years by now
um and I in my opinion I think breeders
are hesitant to change because a it's
hard to
find it's hard to find the Gen genetic
diversity Within These breeds to do that
if you set out to say Okay I want to
make two French Bulldogs breed and
produce puppies that are less Breaky
spyic but all I can find is French
Bulldogs that are currently Breaky calic
you're have great difficulty in doing
that and you're left with the situation
of what's called outcrossing where you
basically mix breeds together and try to
change the entire shape of the dog but
breeders I think don't want to do that
because then they're making dogs that
are not the breed standard and they face
a lot of criticism from other breeders
who then will blast them across social
media and wherever else and say you're
making poor examples of XYZ breed and
they face a lot of you know peer
pressure I I think think from what I've
seen uh that way so and I and I think
it's hard to hear um you know the thing
I've been making and nurturing in my
mind for many years and in many
generations in my family is perhaps you
know not in the best interest of the
overall dog population as a whole I I
think that's hard news to take a lot of
the time thank you representative Murray
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question another question that
I had was we we've spent a lot of time
around the
condition of brachio but are there other
conditions that you see in treat that
you I'm looking at the the inclusion of
this L thank you if I may follow up
thank you um and so how does one
interpret if we were looking at lines
four five and six which conditions would
be included in addition to brachio If
This Were to be interpreted legally uh
you referring to the bill itself correct
okay okay um can I see I I don't
remember what lines four five and six
say there copies on the table
there I can just read it if you want
okay just to clarify I was asking around
lines four five and six and the
interpretation of
um a birth deform formity that causes
suffering such as and it mentions one
condition but you are yeah I mean you
could
name many deformities you know that dogs
suffer from as congenital malformations
I mean hydrophilus spinal
kyphosis uh cingo Melia and Cavaliers I
mean there's there's I I can literally
just you could find a book and just
start naming them um I do you know and
that gets into I think from you know you
all's perspective a little bit of a
hairy situation as far as like how to
approve these sorts of things like why
stop here and that sort of question um
what I will say is that I think Breaky
seil is probably a good starting point
because if you pay attention to like the
8020 rule in theory um Breaky seil I
think is going to be responsible for
more of the health problems than
anything else um by and large
um is it the single worst thing that
could be Malou wared about a dog not
always but the sheer number of these
pets times how much it affects them I
think produces a value that probably
will be the the most um the most
rewarding to tackle as a
whole I represent
ger thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question so I I have my kind
of go-to vet in in my community that I
always reach out to on these issues uh
for for her advice and and she was very
sympathetic to to this bill but her
concern um that I I wish to ask you
about has to do
with the the part of the bill that you
know have have in front of you that
refers to the uh same birth deformity
that causes suffering and the question
of of her her concern was you know when
she sees dogs even as they're diagnosed
with boas it's on a scale from one to
four right so how would you envision as
a practicing veterinarian something like
this being implemented because there's
one thing to to understand the purpose
of it it's another thing to say when
we're trying to judge suffering as the
qualifier for whether or not animals
should be bred um how in your mind might
something like this actually be
implemented um I would use the uh I
believe it was out of the Cambridge uh
the Boaz grading skill um and and
basically I think the guidelines
overseas is to breed only grade zero or
one dogs together um and I I think that
is a good guideline to start with
however as a neurologist I'm a little
bit biased because you know I actually
don't um I only deal with the the
neurologic aspect of these breeds which
I see almost every day and I do think
that the dishevel 2 variant in these
breeds does not get talked about enough
um Studies have shown that this is fixed
in French English bulldogs and I believe
Boston ter or pugs don't not but
definitely French and English Bulldogs
um I I think ridding the breed of also
that spinal Mal formation is equally as
important as as ridding them of this
Boaz prevalence it's very helpful thank
you thank
you representative
kraton thank thank you madam chair and
thank you for your testimony I'm going
to put you in the fight right now in the
family my daughter's is a vet and one of
my best friends is a vet and they're on
both sides of this issue sure
so ask you a question real quick are are
they on the side that the bill just has
faulty language or are they on the side
that breakie se is okay my daughter 45
minutes RI my ear off it's got to pass
is it's got to pass it's got to pass
pass it will not pass my best friend was
it can't pass okay so yeah here I am
here you are um my question though is
really to
the concept that
breeders can take care of this right
that's that's the argument from the the
vet that said leave it alone right I I
think the the best answer to that is
just look at the breed standards the
breed standards show and they call for
dogs with extremely short noses if that
is your North Star to create a dog
you're going to create dogs as extremely
short noosed as you can
as part of building this population and
if you're going to do that
yes very many will overcome that
disability like I said in my statement
but you're going to have collateral
damage in the form of just swaths of
dogs as a result of this practice that
are suffering from sometimes day one
okay um and I I think one of the biggest
things that could change would be the
breed clubs changing the language and
stop I think what the AKC rep was
talking about Boston teror breed
standard you can you can look it up
right now the breed standard shows a
correct Breaky spalet dog and an
incorrect less Breaky calic dog the
muzzle is longer and they call it
incorrect so if you're a breeder and you
want to make these dogs you're going to
look at that and think well I want to
make the correct one but that means
everything's going like this with the
muzzle so I think that's probably the
best place to start okay thank you so
much appreciate it
yep U representative
Penza um I love representative um
kraton's question because it's kind of
like where I'm at how can we legislate
this I think it's almost impossible but
um the other the two other um the woman
from the AKC and then the other woman
that's sitting next to her um their
testimonies were really powerful so and
I'm here looking at this chart that has
you know says okay if we want to not
have
um you know the the boas problem this is
where you would
breed so you're saying is this not being
followed by the Breeders right now I
think it's contradictory because
research has also shown that the shorter
that a muzzle gets the higher the risk
exponentially of Boaz happening that is
that is disputed amongst the Breeders
but that and another study is
misinterpreted as counteracting the
study that showed a very clear
relationship across all dogs as the
muzzle goes like this the risk of Boaz
goes like that on a graph okay um I
think it's it's contradictory because on
the one hand they're encouraging that
but then they show you a picture of a
dog with no nose on their breed standard
website so I I don't know how to make
you sure wouldn't followup
representative Katon and H yes thank you
one one question this is clarification
because we've
had to me conflicting testimony today on
the definition of
brachio Breaky s Breaky yes sir thank
you uh as a medical condition or just a
description of a flat face it's a
description of of the skull okay and
that description it's like saying round
like how round is something okay right
thank
you okay any other questions thank you
for your testimony sir yep oh
representative kto I'm sorry thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question sorry as I sit here and listen
and I listen to and representative Katon
just clarified one thing along with your
answer Breaky calic is a description it
is not a medical condition Brey spalc
Brey is that correct
yes may I I just heard testimony and I
don't know if it's correct but the breed
uh pinies
um was discussed briefly and that
standard hasn't my understanding was
it's over a thousand years old
um but they would be considered Breaky
spal right I believe they are yes okay
now how would we why would we legislate
something on a breed that is over a
thousand years old that we haven't heard
anything going on with regards to I mean
we've been talking about a lot of breeds
but Pines is also one of these
breeds what is your suggestion and what
do we do with all of these animals if we
going to legislate that these people
really can't read again because they're
causing they're a Breaky calic breed I'm
just asking well I think that if you
start the question is how it like in a
theoretical world how to start this
process of unwinding the severe extreme
Fe
um I would think there would have to be
some sort of grace period to say okay
you have X amount of time to start
unwinding this process so that you know
initially all we have are break ealc
dogs in many cases so like what else are
we going to breed them to right so I
think they need time to demonstrate you
know are we making progress and Headway
here um and I think a lot of good faith
as I've said before a lot of kind of
good faith towards that would be the
breed clubs changing what they are
recommending and showing as primary
examples of these pets um I'd also like
to bring up the fact that there's
there's varying degrees of break eil so
like some people mention boxers as a
breed and lump them in with French and
English bulldogs and say Well they're
break EOP valid why they don't have
these if you look at boxers how many
boxers have you seen who have completely
no face whatsoever there there's degrees
to this condition too and that's why I
use the analogy that it's like calling
something round because you know a
soccer ball is not a perfect sphere but
you would describe it as round in
general right um having said that boxers
are a much elevated risk for malignant
brain cancer and that is directly
related to the genes that confer brachy
onto them so the genes that change the
shape of their skull have other
ramifications outside of just their
respiratory system represent kto thank
you but couldn't that be true of any
breed uh true of well I mean any breed
can pass on uh genetic or uh or
deformity um I know that at one point I
had a breed I had to make sure I got a
hip displasia um certificate uh to say
that they were free and clear of that
and that my dog would replace because it
is a genetic deformity or genetic defect
in that particular breed it was my
choice to buy from the breeder who I
thought was very upfront and honest with
me and I had a wonderful animal right
there are other breeds that are
subjective to cancer genes now what
specific cancer Gene well you know
things we I'm not sure I'm not a
veterinarian but G genetically even as
humans we are predisposed by our parents
okay to get genetic defects or abnor
abnormalities this can happen in any
breed of dog not just the braisy so what
is your answer to um comat combating all
of these well for one I think this is a
false equivalency I don't think that
referring to other breeds like um let's
say Bernie Mountain Dogs and they're
massively overrepresented for a
malignant cancer that is incurable and
their lifespan in some studies are
reported as six to eight years they die
of this called his malignant
histiocytosis okay
um that cancer if you could identify a
single genetic test to say okay this dog
is going to demonstrate this cancer I
promise you everybody would be on board
with saying okay yeah let's get get this
out of the breed the problem is you
cannot at least to my knowledge
currently do that and you have to wait
until the dog is about 7 or eight years
old to develop the cancer many times
they develop these problems after
they've reproduced okay whereas many of
these dogs who are Brey calic will
demonstrate these problems before they
reproduce or they are simply born with a
shape that we know puts them at risk for
it okay um so again I I think the
question is what can we identify to fix
and you mentioned the grading the Boaz
grading scale and you know simply
visually inspecting um the the two uh uh
parents of any potential Offspring I
think would be you know much easier than
trying to say um you know are these dogs
going to end up producing cancer in
eight years after they're
born representative
Bixby yeah so one of the things I'm
struggling with is that um we have
before us two different things we have a
problem which you have documented fairly
well that uh there are uh there are
certain
uh certain um diseases uh that or um
physiological um uh problems that come
with brais phalic dogs uh not 100% but
you know with a certain degree of
predictability and we also have before
us a bill and what the bill does is uh
make the selling or breeding of such
dogs uh and animal cruelty of an
equivalent to um neg negligently failing
to feed your animals uh or
negligently um you know causing other
sorts of suffering to your animals I'm
not going to go through the whole list
but but so what we're looking at is uh
something a list of Cruelty behaviors
that are generally policed by local law
enforcement or local Animal Control
Officers and are um and I'm wondering
how that the enforcement system that uh
we have for someone who is hoarding
animals is going to be the same be
effective for uh for dealing with
problems that have to do with let's say
errors of judgment and breeding or
errors of um in systemic practice in
breeding I'm not I'm not sure how this
bill is actually going to
effectively address what is a seems to
be a systemic problem in uh the in
patterns of breeding yeah no I I agree
like that that's um that's more of
a sound crass there more of a you
problem than a my problem you know um
but uh no I I I hear what you're saying
that that makes perfect sense like how
do we use what we have now to enforce
this um I would say I would not rely on
anything other than a
veterinarian and if you really want to
be precise and fair and balanced you
should have a specialist veterinarian
such as a board certified surgeon or an
internist or an
anesthesiologist um
neurologist um one of these types of
people assess potential breed stock and
make that conclusion and you probably
should wait until a certain age um to
assess them in the first place follow up
followup y um so um I don't know if this
is even within the realm possibility but
would it make more sense rather than
having this in the criminal code to uh
impose some sort of legal regulation on
the way that breed standards are created
um I I think that's a decent idea yeah
yeah I could I could see I could I could
get my head around that yeah thank you
any other
questions seeing none I'm going to move
along here and uh thank you for your
Ferrari
good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee thank you for taking uh
the time out of your day to hear our
opposition to this Bill I'm here on
behalf of dog owners of the Granite
State um and I know I've explained to
you our organization before but we
present a wide variety of breeders and
clubs throughout New Hampshire including
cats and dogs um I'm going to touch on a
few things today um I'm going to run
through them really quick increased
seizure of dogs undermine significance
of Health certificates and the P
potential for legal conflicts if you
have questions on those if I don't get
to them let me know I'm going to touch
on really quickly a few things we've
heard come up today to try and clarify
for you um first I would like to say
that we are all very sympathetic to
Penny's story um we don't discount what
she has gone through with her dog in any
way what I do want to remind all of us
is that she purchased her dog from a
breeder in Ohio and we are here today to
talk about the breeders of bralic dogs
here in New Hampshire and identifying if
we have an issue here that our
legislator need legislation needs to
address which I think we have heard so
far we do not um based on Stacy over
from the akc's testimony on what was
submitted for complaints to the
department we have not had any in
regards to bopic dogs and I think that's
really important when we're starting to
look at making it a criminal offense or
requiring other restrictions based on
the breeding of those dogs so please
keep in mind that that's why we're here
quickly to the color question that we
had earlier uh one piece that didn't get
addressed is that there are non-standard
colors and those are signs that bre
breeders are not breeding to the
standard and that's a red flag so that's
could be something like a Merl Frenchie
if you see that that isn't a breeder
that you want to buy from additionally
on insurance true panion offers coverage
from day one on go home day and I'm not
aware of any restrictions based on breed
all right moving forward into my actual
testimony uh in the event that breeding
these type of dogs is officially
classified as animal cruelty it would
Empower officers of duly licensed Humane
Society to intervene by taking such
animals into temporary protective
custody upon probable cause of Cruelty
by the owners this provision while
intended to protect the wellbe being of
animals also poses challenges for dog
breeders and prospective pet owners if
you were to look to RSA 644 colon 8
Roman numeral 4- a and a in parentheses
where it states that an officer of a
duly licensed Humane Society may take
into temporary prote itive custody any
animal when there is probable cause to
believe that it is or has is excuse me
that it has been or is being abused an
unintended consequence of the proposed
legislation is the potential for an
escalation in seizures of basophilic
dogs or any other breeds targeted as
having birth deformities by Humane
Societies in New Hampshire as the demand
for specific breeds Rises due to the
scarcity of the breeders in the state
rescues and shelters may feel compelled
to step in to meet demand uh this could
inadvertently lead shelters to be
compelled to Target remaining breeders
and seizing their animals for financial
gain um moving I believe your time is up
I'm sorry okay are there any
questions from the
committee so with with regard to
um the the
Breeders that you mentioned about
seizures yes C what what what part of
the law were you referencing that if you
look at 644 colon 8 Roman numeral 4- a
there is a specific line that says that
if you are if there is probable cause
that you are inflicting animal cruelty
which we're talking about these birth
deformities becoming animal cruelty that
a duy licensed Humane officer would be
able to go in and take temporary custody
of the animals um one of the biggest
questions we've had here is how are we
going to determine if the dogs are being
intentionally bred if they have the
deformity and have been being sold and
if we have a breeder in the state that
is
potentially under animal cruelty
breaking the law these breeders could
have their animals seized as part of
this new law based on what we have here
in place M and what about um so I know
you breed animals
can you describe a little bit about um
the level of control you have as a
breeder um
regarding the the outcome of the of the
litter sure um little little control um
as mentioned earlier is there is science
behind it it is an art you know in
choosing what we're going to have for
the parents to try and produce the ideal
puppy who's going to be healthy good
temperament live a long life life um and
then there is Mother Nature you know
things are potentially going to happen
that we have no control over so while we
do intend to do the very best that we
can um sometimes birth deformities can
happen uh I myself personally did have a
puppy that was born with a liver shunt
which did not appear until she was about
6 months old she was in her home loved
by her new owner and it was a very
devastating experience that we went
through together um I will mention that
she did go through and get her health
certificate which I think is really
important was touched on briefly earlier
um but Health certificates are issued
here in New Hampshire by a licensed
veterinarian and they're critical
documents that provide Assurance to
perspective pet owners when a burer
provides health certificate along with
the sale of a dog they are testing to
the animal's Health um so our health
certificates no longer a certificate of
the health of an animal here in New
Hampshire if if they aren't there to do
the job um if something was to happen
down the road so if no health issues or
deformities were identified during the
veterinary examination the breeder is
not knowingly selling a sick or deformed
animal but there is another piece of
Statute related to health certificates
and the selling of deformed animals that
I'd like to elaborate on if I may sure
what what statute is that this is 437
colon a Roman numeral 2 it allows for
waiver if the animal is being sold with
a non-contagious medical condition which
could include certain deformities uh the
provision recognizes that not all
medical conditions are necessarily
debilitating or harmful to the animal's
welfare and allows for the flexibility
in the sale process so if HB 1102 were
to pass it could create a conflicting
situation in the law on one hand Health
certificates provide Assurance to
animals Health at the time of purchase
while on the other hand the legislation
May May classify the sale of the dog
with certain deformities as animal
cruelty so this inconsistency could
create confusion and legal ambiguity for
breeders and purchasers alike
potentially discouraging responsible
breeding practices and limiting consumer
choice and and that was
437a 437 colon a Roman numeral
2 so that's in the health certificate
section um so it's important to
acknowledge that although Veterinary
examinations are critical some medical
conditions and or deformities may not be
immediately apparent so that's why we
always recommend that purchasers are
insist on getting a contract with their
breeder okay would you think that there
should be any place on the health
certificate to show that there is some
sort of genetic
issue possible genetic issue with the
animal I will leave that to our
veterinarian who's going to speak a
little bit further but I do know when I
have ever had a situation with a puppy
for example I had one that had an
umbilical hernia very mild didn't
require any surgery usually as they get
larger they outgrow it and I my
veterinarian did indicate that on the
health certificate so that the owner was
aware of the situation so they knew what
they were
buying okay representative Bixby yeah I
just uh wanted to um point a little
slight clarification on uh 437 colon 82
about the health certificate waiver uh
the the the reason that that is there is
because it is possible to have a dog
that has a health problem but it is not
a contagious health problem and in that
case it makes sense to have the uh
potentially have uh an order for that
dog who would be able to take care of
the the animal and would be aware of
that health problem uh but it so uh one
of the so there's the health certificate
has to do both with screening for what
might be contagious which you just don't
want to get out there right and also
screening and also screening for uh
hereditary problems or or non-contagious
problems and the waiver allows for the
non-contagious problems uh to the dog
can still be transferred even if there's
a non-contagious problem okay thank you
for clarifying that yep which could be a
deformity that could technically
depending on who was evalua it be
considered to cause
suffering okay any other questions from
the committee seeing none thank you very
much thank
you um yeah I think I want to take a
five minute break in case anybody needs
to go to the bathroom or just uh because
we've been at this for three hours and
uh just a five minute break and then
back
I'm going to ask our committee members
seats I would like our committee members
seats is this just one sheet yeah
there's another one coming oh okay
okay thank you for getting back uh so
quickly and I guess we are going to
resume we've got still several pinks
pink cards and I hope we can get through
this fairly quickly um I will say that I
have um one pink card that's in support
and the rest of them are in opposition
to uh HB 1102 if there is anyone else
who wishes to speak who supports the
bill I would like to have your pink card
as soon as possible other than that I'm
going to call Martha
speak thank you very much um please put
your microphone on and you have three
minutes thank you thank you very much
this has been such a an interesting um
session and I really appreciate the
information that I've been hearing from
both sides of this issue a full
disclosure Little Penny is my grand doog
so I've been through it with her I just
wanted to say a couple of things briefly
my biggest takeaway from listening to
everything here is
that the breeding standards for
extreme sorry Breaky
seil are the problem that's my biggest
takeaway um that's not a comment on
breeders it's not a comment on anyone I
think it's time for much more Awareness
on this and some changes new stuff comes
up all the time we don't have to live
with stuff that was
happening 50 years ago 100 years ago a
thousand years ago so that was one of
the biggest things
um it's not a breed band breeders I
don't think you need to be afraid of
this it's pretty basic and simple you
cannot intentionally if this is is past
you can't intentionally breed dogs two
dogs with the same
deformity um that causes
suffering um so we may be overco
complicating the issue when we're
talking about genetics and all that sort
of thing
um let's see it's not the breed
themselves that are the problem you know
it's the breeding standards I also
thought um oh the bill it only adds to
the existing definition of Cruelty the
first offense is a misdemeanor somebody
mentioned a felony um and that sort of
thing couple of assumptions that I've
heard that I just wanted to correct one
was Penny was purchased in Ohio not
because my daughter didn't research
breeders in New Hampshire she researched
a breeder in New Hampshire
first and uh found unsatisfactory they
were breeding uh non-standard non-breed
standard colors so she decided to look
elsewhere and she looked all over uh the
Mid-Atlantic
Seaboard
um I kind of get the idea that maybe
breeders aren't necessarily aware of um
the complications of
Boaz because the person that my daughter
went to had no I never mentioned Boaz or
breaki step the vet signed off on this
dog and um you know she came home and a
week later she was near
death um I also think that if we have
healthy breed standards here in New
Hampshire people will flock to breeders
in New Hampshire they won't go elsewhere
I think that's pretty
important
um also one other assumption was that oh
people will report these things to the
state no that's not true my daughter
didn't even want to report it to her the
breeder because she didn't want to hurt
their feelings thank you very much okay
thank you very much any
questions okay thank you for your
testimony Diane
Tyrie I think it is
Ty
Tyre
afternoon
okay
um my name is Diane Tyrie I'm a resident
of hollus and a former breeder of
Tibetan spaniels I currently live with
poor geriatric Tibetan spaniels at Rag
and age from 11 to
14 I have passed out some information
about the
Boaz grading or functional test system
everybody has talked about it but nobody
has talked about the various
grades I think it's important to
understand that these dogs are graded
from one to
three a one being a perfectly clear dog
and a three being a dog that has been
classified as
effective
affected that being said my big question
is what do breeders do with dogs that or
puppies that are classified as a three
and
effective that cannot be
sold do they euthanize them something
that has to be
considered I'd also like to make you
aware of eight ancient dog breeds from
China and Tibet that have been
classified as brachio calic and survived
despite the inhospitable climate and
topography of those areas these are the
Chinese Sharpe the chowchow the Pug the
pinies the Japanese Chin with roots in
China the Lassa Absa the Tibetan Spaniel
and the shitzu from
Tibet these breeds have
survived 2,000 years or
more there many of them are long lived
breeds the
current Lee the average life of a Pines
is longer than that of a golden
retriever in that new
study there has been a lot of concern
about brachio phalic breeds and their
health a lot of it is exaggerated and
incorrect as an AKC judge of Lassa opsis
in tibetan spaniels I have to question
how either of these breeds could be
considered brachio phalic yet both are
listed as being so so therefore I ask
you to take a long look at the history
of these ancient
breeds the accuracy of classification of
the breeds as brachio falic and the
availability of current testing methods
when you make your
decision okay thank you you times up any
questions any questions from the
committee representa
Murray thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question with regard
to the grading now correct me if I'm not
wrong I believe there was a veterinarian
who tested that there was a grading
scale 0o to four and so I'm curious what
the
difference I don't know about the zero
online
okay okay but thank you I was curious to
as to know whether or not you had come
across that I have not come across a
zero to four I everything I had found
was a zero to three grading system okay
okay thank you representative ger I yeah
thank you I just wanted to say for point
of clarification I had referred to a
note I got from my veterinarian who
referred to one through four so I
suspect the can of 1 through four
equates to Z three through three so four
categories yeah I think that was the
confusion yeah thank you for the
clarification that Mak thank you okay
thank you for your testimony uh Jane
Barlo
Roy good afternoon um I have testified
in front of you guys before um but to
reintroduce myself my name is Dr Jane
maroy I am um representing the New
Hampshire Veterinary Medical Association
and as delegate to the American veter
Medical Association I have been a pra
practitioner here in the conquered area
for just about 18 years and I did grow
up here in New Hampshire and londonairy
um in lie of reading my written
testimony that I will give to
representative com
um I will just make the point of further
defining the different types of sees
because there are three known uh sees uh
that the American veter Medical
Association Association um defines um as
well as my Veterinary textbooks so we
have mesio falic which means average
face which is your Labradors and um
those sort of dogs we have Olio falic
which is a longer nose dog um such as
your Collies um and your Dobermans and
then we have brachos phalic which is
short-face dogs um or they can also be
applied to other animals cats um and and
such so with that I defer to questions
um because I know your time is just as
valuable as our time is okay do you you
know if there are
um also sey breeds that are in farm
animals at all like pigs or cows or it's
been a very long time since at school
I'm a small animal practitioner okay um
I can only remember the things that I
see in in in the the my normal
day-to-day life so I'm sure there are um
and I would defer to the large animal
Specialists okay representative Katon
I'm sorry just are you opposed to this
bill or I am opposed yes I'm I'm I'm in
opposition to
just want to make sure thank you for the
record representative Bixby so in your
time as a vet have you run across many
animals that are uh suffering from the
conditions that have been cited uh in
today in my almost 18 years I have come
across many different disease processes
cancers other sorts of deformities that
do cause suffering um uh I could
probably be here for the next several
hours to several days going through that
that's probably why I had four years of
veterinary school um that's what our our
our job was in veterinary school was to
learn all these different things there
are processes that are specific to
certain breeds um and I think we would
be remiss
in calling them all deformities um
because we do know that there are
certain breeds of dogs that are more
prone to heart disease than others we
know that there are more dogs that are
prone to cancers than others we know
that there are breeds of cats that are
more prone to upper respiratory
infections um but that doesn't mean that
that all falls under the the definition
of birth deformity or birth
defect okay thank you any other
questions from the
committee thank you appreciate it I
think one more kind of point to to your
if if we started to go down that trail
um and started to say well we can't
breed Labradors because they are more
prone to lymphoma we can't breed Golden
Retrievers because they are more prone
to homio saroma we can't breed beagles
because they are prone to obesity we're
going to be left with no animals um so I
think that that's that's the that's our
concern with this particular
belt okay thank Youk appreciate it and I
do have written testimony that the abma
has all
good afternoon uh thank you for letting
me testify this is so neat to be in New
Hampshire and be able to do this I've
lived in other states when I was younger
and could never get to say hello to the
governor or hello to Representatives so
thank you um just briefly I am a breeder
I have been in the breed that I chose
which was Irish Water Spaniels although
my mother chose it and then I followed
through um since
1958 I've been a breeder myself since
1990 or excuse me 1980 and I just wanted
you to hear from a Breeder's perspective
this is very frightening to us for you
for a bill to be set in front of you
listing things that quote we've done
wrong over the years and now somebody
else is going to correct it um my breed
standard is very specific it calls for a
gate it calls for curly hair it calls
for smooth face um and a tail with no
hair on it um it's every breed has its
characteristics and when we read this
bill right away we said whoa
deformity gee your nose doesn't look
like mine am I deformed or are you
deformed you know you
you when you get into I'm also an
emergency nurse so I do understand the
process when somebody has a deformity
like a rounded back they won't have good
breathing things like that so I do
understand that but I'm not sure we can
legislate that I don't believe that's
true and I think that one of the
Breeders that I've talked to are
frightened they are very frightened that
you'll start on this slope and we'll go
right
downhill M and I just have one more
thing to say thank you so much for
sitting here and listening to all of us
and each year I get to stand up at the
emergency nurses convention and be the
only state in the United States and
abroad that doesn't have a primary seat
belt law but I still wear mine so anyhow
thank you very much yes yeah
representative kto thank you madam chair
could you just tell me um what IW oh
it's the Irish Water spanel Club of
America America and we have probably 50
or 80 I I think it's now 80
International people and we have a small
breed um maybe 200 members but we're
Mighty and we drink
Boer
more comments about
that good afternoon chairman Aon and
committee members I'm Dr Lisa Boer and
I'm a New Hampshire resident in
Veterinary and licensed I need you to
speak into the microphone sorry about
that thank you can I start from yeah no
go ahead all right chairman Aon and
committee members I'm Dr Lisa Boer and
I'm a New Hampshire resident and
veterinarian licensed in New Hampshire
and Maine I have more than two decades
ades of of experience in K9 reproduction
and personally breed dogs by way of
background prior to becoming a vet I was
an Air Force officer and an FBI agent
I'm an AKC breeder of Merit I have been
an emergency and critical care as well
as a general practitioner veterinarian
for 22 years and I'm a court qualified
expert in matters related to Kine Health
breeding purebred dog ownership and
registration as well as animal cruelty
and abuse in multiple jurisdictions I've
participated in cases about animal abuse
cruelty and neglect across the country
and I currently contract with the New
Hampshire stratum SPCA as a veterinarian
for this purpose in fact I was a meeting
at a meeting 3 days ago with them and
that they also opposed this bill I have
devoted my life to the Health and
Welfare of animals and my life revolves
around dogs both personally and
professionally I'm vehemently opposed to
this bill and it is a bill full of
erroneous assumptions and unforeseen
consequences reputable breeders do know
their pedigrees and conduct recommended
Health testings and do their best to
produce healthy dogs it is propos is to
tell me that by breeding a healthy dog
I'm committing animal abuse potentially
a felony by virtue of an illd defined
term alluding to a phenotypic headshape
there is no standard definition of
braisy and I've given you some research
to support that it does describe a wide
variation in the appearance of skull and
equating that braisy with a deformity or
animal cruelty is misinformed and not
true braisy is not only seen in domestic
species but it also occurs as a natural
adaptation in species to its environment
it occurs in sheep goats cattle horses
Birds pigs rabbits dogs cats and even
human and it is not always pathologic HP
1102 could extend to other species as
well there are a lot of studies out
there that will discuss the implications
of Boaz and other health problems uh
with brachy the problem isn't with
brachy itself it's with any trait in an
animal that occurs in the extreme um I
would uh respectfully tell you that that
the neurologist who testified he sees a
very biased population he's a specialist
he doesn't see the general pet
population I would tell you that most of
the braches phalic animals that I see in
practice over my 22 years do not suffer
from these and it certainly isn't a 90%
occurrence in any breed I have research
as well that supports that for you um
breeding also refers to not just putting
two dogs together or two animals
together but also the production of
those animals so if I breed two non
affected animals and come up with an
affected animal I could still be held
accountable under this law that's the
way I interpreted it so this would
essentially stop me from ever breeding a
dog in the state of New Hampshire again
so that is concerning to me the um other
issue that I left with you if I can just
have one comment is that there's a study
that I did reference in my um in my
testimony that discusses the impact of
an educational intervention on of uh
public perception of braches phalic dogs
and it showed that 97% of people after
given proper Educational Tools about the
problems that can happen not that do
always
happen had a much better understanding
of it and were more informed and it is
not the skull that equates equates with
the dog's problem it's the openness of
their nostrils and other ratios in their
neck and uh neck and girth and body
weight is probably one of the most
biggest indicator of Boaz not braisy
and that that research has been provided
to you in my
testimony and I am happy to answer any
questions um regarding pet insurance
suffering and evaluating an animal for
suffering as well as the general pet
population and Animal Welfare
representative Bixby so it sounds like
you're the person to ask my question yes
I sat there back there going just yes
I'm happy to answer so um so I'm
wondering what the procedure is uh if
you could just describe what the
procedure is for doing an investigation
for animal cruelty under uh 648 uh 6448
sure so first you know the the complaint
must be brought to you know an agency so
that would come to either an animal
welfare agency or potentially even an
attorney general or law enforcement they
would reach out to the Animal Welfare or
Animal Control Officers who would then
go and investigate the complaint
sometimes with or without a veterinarian
present they don't have a large number
of people like me that go out and do
that um then if there's probable cause
to suspect that the complaint is true
then they may go in with a team from the
SPCA or from Animal Welfare they then
would potentially seize those animals
into custody they would come into
custody and be examined by somebody like
me who then would document all of the
health problems that would exist with
that population of animals and determine
whether or not that animal I don't make
the determination of abuse or neglect
that's jurisdictionally determined but I
would make my opinion about the
condition of that animal and whether it
was something that was neglect or
abuse follow up so um given that
um with the description with uh the
description of animal abuse that is uh
create would be created by this bill how
would that be dealt with it can't be
it's impossible absolutely impossible
thank you representative
Murray thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question so I guess
with regard to the I think it was one of
the previous speakers and your testimony
um with the possibility of animals being
removed from the the Y sure right the
possession of anyone and that is during
the investigation
process pre-trial potentially as the
investigation process is going on if
there's probable cause to support the
bringing of charges against somebody for
animal cruelty abuse or neglect then
those animals can be seized follow up if
I may follow up Y and do you find that
in this bill that is a potential
absolutely thank you okay any other
questions from the
committee yeah representative ktoa thank
you madam chair and uh thank you for
taking my question um just so I
understand everything and everything
we've been
hearing brachy seil is a description of
an animal being flat-faced or flath
headed is that correct I would say it's
the and there's no one universal
definition as evidence by one of the
studies I gave you but brachy sefali is
typically used to a wide flat skull it's
not always flat face so this poster here
shows you all the different animals and
not all of them but many EX examples of
perfectly healthy animals that are
Breaky spalc and by this bill and the
wording of this bill would fall under
animal cruelty follow up thank you for
that having owned two of the breeds that
are considered
Ries um under this because it's just a
definition and not a condition could it
would it be possible for anyone owning
those animals to be considered in
violation um because they're owning an
animal so I'm just wondering where could
they be seized I
mean under this the ownership isn't what
is as my understanding of the bill is
written it's not ownership that's the
problem okay it's it's the breeding of
these animals and this bill the problem
I see is it can be applied retroactively
because I willingly bred this litter you
know I intentionally bred a litter I may
have had unforeseen consequences of that
breeding and please understand everybody
talked about the genetics and all of
that that really doesn't take into
account the genetics is not black and
white there are environmental influences
that dictate whether or not an animal
develops something that could or could
not be genetic there's also a field
called epigenetics that changes a dog's
DNA at its core to then produce you know
undesirable things representative comor
follow thank thank you madam chair and
thank you again for taking my question
sure so if what if someone was breeding
these animals and they're perfectly
healthy could the environment in which
they're being raised cause some of these
issues I'm so glad you asked me that
question um let's take hip dysplasia if
you ask me as a 22-year practicing
veterinarian the number one disease
process that causes suffering in animals
I would tell you it's hip dysplasia
happens in tons of of breeds lots of
large dogs that disease is not only
genetic it's multifactorial it comes to
diet exercise the flooring on which it
was raised as a puppy it can be um the
flooring that it's raised in you know in
a household people who have slick floors
who have wood floors like we do you know
that dog will be more predisposed so
correlation does not equal causation and
that's what I I really hope that this
committee can understand brachy spyic
breeds yes do they have Boaz sure do
they have other issues sure but it
doesn't mean by virtue of their breed or
the brachy that they're going to have it
they're correlated but they're not
necessarily caused by that the idea that
um by having a dog with a flatter skull
that it's necessarily going to have this
no their their body weight determines
whether they can regulate their body
temperature much more so the studies
that I've given you show that the number
one contributor is not the length of
their muzzle but yet their body weight
and their girth of their neck I mean so
I mean these are scientific studies and
I I just don't um 90% of Frenchies do
not have Boaz I'm sorry I don't know
where those statistics come from I've
done my
research any other questions from the
committee okay
um I you know I
um I have to again we you know we're
talking about
um just dogs actually we've been talking
all day dogs with u
braisy
but are there are there any
other any other uh and is this is this
really a deformity I'm just no it is it
occurs in nature and that's you know in
my testimony I talk about birds PE I
mean animals adapt to their environment
now you know certainly brachy in an
extreme case can be breed to be
undesirable
but animals are naturally braic in
undomesticated species as well as
domesticated species and they they do
have adaptations that occur based on
their environment and so no it is a
descriptor and not a deformity or
condition absolutely not it's not
recognized in any Veterinary textbook as
an
um breathing disorders I mean aside from
asthma kind of things that are uh traits
of certain other animals there are a lot
of breathing dis breathing disorders
that are traits in many animals um
feline asthma is is one of them I mean
that's a that's a condition that's very
you know not related to break esopo but
it is a condition that's common um you
know animals have pulmonary disease for
a wide variety infectious reasons
tickborne reasons I mean there many many
things that could cause breathing
difficulties but from a from a and I
think you're we're overly focused on
breathing because there there's just so
many disorders in animals that can occur
based on um a breed it's you know based
on any breed even non- breed I mean you
can take two like the Doodles are not
pure bread everybody loves Doodles those
are some of the most unhealthy animals I
see in practice they all have skin
allergies I mean almost all of them and
they their owners are spending thousands
of dollars they're on chronic
medications for their life so you know
the general population is not the
extreme that you're being presented here
today and I just really want you to
understand 22 years is an emergency vet
I don't think that I have
[Music]
seen 10 Boaz affected dogs to the point
where they were suffering and dying I
mean we're talking about I'm not that it
doesn't happen and I'm one veterinarian
but this isn't something that comes
through my door every day okay this is
this is definitely not the New Hampshire
population of
dogs Okay so this we're talking a lot
about um skull structure yes here but in
terms of other parts of animals can they
also have uh some structures that would
quote unquote cause suffering suffering
absolutely um take York Yorkshire
Terriers I mean those cute little yorkis
I can tell you that many of those their
livers develop more slowly in their
ability to um regulate their blood
sugars okay and I see weekly see very
small breed dogs come in because they
can't regulate their blood sugars and
then they're in the hospital on IVs and
dextr strips and things to bring that up
and the owners have to give that animal
Special Care liver shuns are a great
example of that there are internal
things that you can't see from the
outside that you know animals can suffer
but they but many of these things can be
medically or surgically managed and or
or husbandry practices even keeping a
dog at the right weight goes a long way
to solving a lot of these problems as
well okay thank you representative
German thank you madam chair thank you
very much for your testimony for
answering my question so what I'm
struggling here with is I understand
certain breeds are prone to certain
disorders right as certain genetic
groups and human populations are prone
to certain disorders right but the
question here has to do with artificial
selection right so are there other
comparable cases where a specific
aesthetic feature for which animals are
bred have a comparably high correlation
to a specific disorder right because I
understand certain breeds have certain
disorders but what I'm struggling with
it seems to me that whatever the
percentage is there is a correlation a
stronger correlation between certain
physical features that are intentionally
selected for okay and
certain uh medical conditions or we
could talk about invertebral dis disease
long back dogs you know you have a
longer spine certainly they're more
prone in their daily life to wind up
having you know in vetal disc disease
that can be life-ending and
life-changing for a dog you can um have
I can go back to hip dysplasia dogs that
are bred for a certain bone structure
and the slope of their back and just
their confirmation in general can have
hip dysplasia I mean so there there are
many of these examples but I think we're
unnecessarily focused on one condition
and you know and braak eepy I think this
unfortunately would then extend to the
greater population and a lot of times I
can do as a breeder the best job that I
can to ensure the health of a litter and
I you know and do all my health testing
and clearances and everything else and
breed the best of what I have and
something can go wrong either not
genetically but developmentally from
embryonic development or um or even
environmental influences to cause some
of these things and we can't control for
that we just can't it's Mother Nature
you know it's very helpful thank you
very much thank you thank you any other
questions from the
committee thank you very much for your
testimony it was very helpful
today
okay
okay all right um so we have one two
three four five six 78 people uh who
have submitted pink cards and if you
have something I if you were planning on
saying something that somebody's already
said um it would be appreciated if you
waved off but uh because time is running
ducet
and thank you I'll I'll be brief because
a lot of it's been touched upon but um
firstly dly s set I am strongly oppose
this bill I don't come to you as a
breeder a vet but purely a a pet
Enthusiast and I happen to own a dog in
this targeted group that we're talking
about today but understand that with the
lingo in this
bill it certainly is a slippery slope
but to me it can Cascade and kind of
focus on what I would consider
characteristics of breeds and start to
think that that is a deformity I think
what we should be doing is promoting
again these reputable breeders to that
have the lifetime contracts with their
customers like me I happen to own a
German shepherd and I actually happen to
own an Old English Bulldog name Olive
she I have lifetime contract with my
breeders I'm I could contact them
anytime they've all been Health tested
so I think that's kind of the road we
all want to go down and as an aside one
reason why we did get our Bulldog
because we didn't know much about the
breed so we did our research found a
breeder in Maine and um this breeder
produced the Bulldog that is the current
mascot at Yale okay they did lifetime
you know uh search throughout the US
settled on this breeder and so far they
have two his name is handsome Dan he has
an Instagram page you can follow it he
and I assure you he has a very robust
active you know uh lifestyle okay so and
lastly just to wrap it up I did I didn't
make copies I apologize I did email you
all and I'd be very happy to walk that
over so thank you for your time any
questions from the committee seeing none
[Music]
Richardson hello my name's Diane
Richardson I'm from Springfield New
Hampshire I've been
involved with dogs both professionally
and as a hobby for 39 years in the
interest of time I'll just hit three
points I emailed you the full testimony
last Thursday um it contains a whole lot
of information I'm
sorry uh the three points are one how
will brachy be diagnosed there are six
different methods and four thresholds
within those that can be used to define
and diagnose a brachy cilic animal which
which I detailed in my email just two of
these methods are muzzle ratio the ratio
of the muzzle to the total head length
and a muzzle length below
33% of the total head length will is
diagnosed as breis spyic or the syphilic
index is a second one uh some people use
the syphilic index which is actually a
measuring system created for human
infants those using the syphilic index
Define
as those animals scoring over one of
three different thresholds either 60
plus or 80 plus or 100 plus using the
syphilic index many breeds of dogs cats
and even
livestock uh that are not flat-faced
will score as brais spalc Cooney Cooney
pigs for
example here are my two dogs chance and
Jenny do they fit your mental definition
of a brachy stolic dog I'm I'm going to
guess
no uh chance scores 82 on the syphilic
index Jenny scores
85 considering these two possible
methods both of those dogs would be
considered as brais spyic as will most
WID headed breeds including the hobu dog
that representative Reed included in her
testimony that dog scores as brachy
spol what is suffering and what is
deformity some deformities could be that
could potentially cause suffering could
be wrinkles long ears short ears
hairlessness short backs long backs
short legs Bowe legs curled eared cats
folded eared cats heavy coat very long
horns curly feathers large feathered
crests fainting goats Etc I'm going to
have to cut you off because you met your
three minutes and then some um any
questions for Miss
Richardson seeing none thank you we
appreciate you hanging in
Farley cop of problem this this is one
of the ones that has
you I am opposed to the bill I don't
have this breed I never have but I have
doberan and there's issues there that
people could come back to us on on that
but what I've did is I did a history
on all the some of the breeds that are
in there that are you know considered
deformed I you know their lifespan
that's what's missing on the majority of
my things because of my like I said my
computer my prints are problem um but
the only thing I want to mention about
all these other dogs other than the
Neapolitan Mastiff they all do um fast
cat or coursing ability which is all
running fast cat a 100 yards straight
down and they take the seconds and put
it into miles per hour so you know every
one of those
breeds do fast cat or coursing they do
obedience they do rally and I just you
know if there's an issue that's where
it's going to come up I would think big
time and to see so many different dogs
breeds doing this that are
supposedly you know having an
issue they're not there it's not there
with these guys so I just you know thank
you any
questions oh representative kto thank
you madam chair would you believe that
my
boxer uh kept up with my boy's dirt
bikes actually kind of went ahead of
them I would I would believe it because
with my dose I we used to do snowball
you know snowmobile and the dog would be
right there running right along with us
and uh the other the other thing is um
of course I lost my train of thought
uh all right I forgot it okay it's kind
any other questions
for seeing none thank you very much uh
Rizzo
hi so my name is Kathy Rizzo I'm here um
on behalf of myself I'm a breeder of
pugs as well as the Pug dog Club of
America which is um operates under the
umbrella of the American kenel Club so
that is the parent club that Stacy was
talking
about there was um so I live in we New
Hampshire I've been dedicated to raising
showing and exhibiting both pugs and
French Bulldogs for almost two
decades I would like you to know I do
oppose this bill um it just unfairly
penalizes responsible breeders like
myself who work tirelessly to maintain
the breed
Integrity um this bill will not only
deter dog acquisition but it will it
will drive to um have buyers go outside
of uh New Hampshire so I just wanted to
clarify one point that was made earlier
on the Pug dog Club of America saying
that they have directly in the standard
the very flat face um in our standard
for the pdca it does say that the nose
is undesirable that the wrinkle comes
over and covers a significant portion of
the nose and it negatively affects the
Pug's ability to breathe comfortably so
I'd like that to be in there
um and that it is undesirable that the
eyes are bulging and East West so when
the eyes come out they go to the side so
I just wanted that for the record um I'd
like to share a few critical points
that's made by one of our Patriot pug
dog club members NE Nelson Lao he is a
PhD biologist and professor of genetics
and biochemistry at Boston University he
argues that brasali is not a birth
defect the skin color uh brasali is like
skin color or height in humans it is
naturally occurring stable trait in
animals it has been intentionally bred
into various dogs and cats through
careful breeding programs over centuries
of domestication many dog breeders
exhibiting bre are healthy and Thrive
with that are raised in suitable
environments often as toys toy breed
that are meant for companionship rather
than working or sporting the presence of
the short nose of these breeds does not
adequate to a
defect um responsible breeders
prioritize animal welfare and breed
preservation criminalizing breeding
regardless of practices is ignores this
commitment protecting responsible
breeding is vital HB 112's blanket
approach overlooks breeding nuances and
natures and contradict our state
principal thank you okay thank you any
questions no okay um I do have a
question are do you know anybody in your
pug Community whose pug dog has had uh
issues with breathing and boas has
needed boas
surgery no uh no um Boaz as far as
um the health testing is fairly new to
the US if if I'm correct so the Pug dog
Club of America is advocating for
breeders to um get that
done okay thank you thank you any other
Holmes
am well some of what I cover in my
testimony um has already been covered by
people um one of the things that was not
was the um Airway syndrome inherited
problem in Norwich teras which are not a
brachy calic breed and yet still have a
known inherited Airway problem which the
Breeders are working to eradicate so
saying it's all brachy spelic breeds
that have a problem like this is
incorrect um as several people stated
braisy is not a condition it's a uh
description of a
skull in terms of this
bill one of the things I want to know is
who can afford to prove time after time
that they had no intent of breeding dogs
that had a
problem um particularly when the dogs
have been seized your dogs have been
seized and you have to pay for all their
Board and
Care so this bill is going to cause
hardship on all
breeders anybody can be accused anybody
can have their dogs
taken I believe that something that
could positively be done to help with
things like this is enforcement of the
health certificate law right now I would
say 95% of the people who sell dogs cats
kittens anything else have no health
certificate that goes with them at
all um something else
um that I did put in my in my notes is I
really wish breeders were as omniscient
as this bill intends us to be because
what this bill intends is that a breeder
is going to know at the time of
conception how the puppies are going to
turn out and sorry not going to happen I
don't know where that 90% number of 90%
of the the bracket calic dogs are
affected came from but I'll tell you
you'll see a picture of my breed a dog
in this I don't usually talk about it I
raised Apen pinches for over 20 years I
was the breed National breed Club
president I was also the national
coordinator for breed rescue and I was
in contact with people nationally and
internation Al so I can tell you I never
heard once of an airway problem with
this breed and it's a brachy pallic
breed so I kind of I'm kind of resenting
being lumped in with the other breeds um
but but the way this bill is written it
works the other thing I find very scary
is those two little words such as that
leaves every breeder wide open and I
have to ask the chair if it's safe can I
read a quote from representative Reed
that was on um the the New Hampshire
animal rights League
website sure I don't okay I I don't want
to offend anybody but it's it's really
confus me between what I'm hearing and
what what I read online on that website
it said representative Ellen Reed wants
to end the breeding of brachy calic
flat-faced dogs and cats who struggle to
breathe and have many other health
problems and then further down the page
it says thanks to representative Ellen
Reed New Hampshire will be the first in
the nation to consider legislation that
would ban the breeding and sale of
brachet calic dogs and cats okay so I
add a little problem I'm going to throw
one more thing at you before I go away
I'm sorry I
just who is being cruel the breeders who
produce the pups or the owners who put
the dogs through surgery after surgery
and keep them in conditions and
overweight that causes the problem who's
the cruel person here um I don't think
it's the Breeders I am prej just about
that but um I'll be happy to answer any
questions I I had a lot more to go but
any question it's been a really long
day quick one so the um the quote that
you read was not her quote it was what
they said in regards to her correct
quotes around it and it said
representative Ellen Reed
said so I'm presuming that that was what
now do I know if they quoted her
correctly hey you know yeah that I that
I that I don't know I just found it very
confused listening testimony here oh
we're not ending it to a website saying
here's the quotes from this
representative saying that we will end
it I understand thank you thank you okay
no other questions from the committee
sir
good afternoon if I could just take one
moment before I start my time on the
testimony I did just want to bring up uh
even though we don't have the current
bill sponsor here I do not appreciate
the fact after we had a
conversation uh regarding being polite
to one another that she felt it
necessary to come over and take photos
of my service dog not only is that
against the Ada that is breaking of my
own privacy so if something could be
said that would be fabulous because that
was very inappropriate thank you okay
thank you uh so my name is Megan bser I
am a proud owner exhibitor and fancier
of the English toy spaniel breed I am
grateful that at this time uh they have
not been mentioned at all in this band
but the band would certainly uh affect
myself and the English toy fanciers so I
am here to discuss um that we are in
opposition of HB 11102 being myself and
English toy spaniel Club of
America as a rare breed with Rich
history leading back to the Victorian
era in King Charles II depictions of
this breed remain nearly untouched since
it was originally documented the English
toy spaniel Club of America standard was
approved by the AKC in
1886 and the last change was made 35
years ago these changes were made to
allow a broader gene pool to ensure that
we are providing a healthier dog in our
production
um research not bias has shown that
length of snout and muzzle does not
equate to the health of an animal
preservation breeders work diligently to
guarantee the Health and Longevity of
our pets and the science behind that
hard work is shown I can say that my
dogs personally I have been part of the
uh boas studies here in the US and all
of my dogs have been graded as a zero
with no concerns um I've also further
been helping Dr rosansky at tus
University to compile research to
further benefit our dogs another
function with the English toy spaniel
Club of America is we have had an
increase in our performance events by
225% um we've had 15 English toy
spaniels that were owned by club members
achiev 58 performance titles which have
included therapy work agility obedience
rally confirmation scent Work Fit dog
and among many others this alone is
proof that our breed is not deformed and
suffering and in fact is thriving in the
same Sports as non- braie dogs competing
keep in mind that we do have a very rare
breed with very low numbers so the fact
that it does see only as 58 dogs is
actually a very high amount in our
breed as my loyal service dog Cedric uh
can show the court he is anything but
deformed he is only an asset to me I'm
sorry he's not only an asset to me but
also an asset to the breed in of pure
bread dogs a deformed and Ill dog would
not be able to be successful in so many
roles from being a showring champion in
multip mle countries Advanced K9 good
citizen titles Sports accomplishments
clear Health testing and more so myself
and the English toy spaniel Club of
America are opposed to the Bill thank
you any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you great
Trahan no okay
no oh okay
okay
Proctor hi hi um I appreciate all that
you do much more now after sitting here
for so long um I'm Sarah Proctor I am a
veterinarian I've been a vet for a long
time I submitted an email that I'm not
going to basically talk at all about
because everybody else has said all of
it except for one thing um I um I work
at the Pope Memorial of me society and
Dover and um I I do oppose this bill for
a lot of the reasons that people other
people have said
um but the the one thing that hasn't
been said relates to how
I imagine this might affect animal
shelters um the language in the bill
suggests that
selling and oh no it says that selling
an animal with the blah blah blah blah
blah is considered
cruelty um and animal shelters we like
to say that we're adopting the animals
but we are transferring ownership for
money um so I think that would make us
fall under this Rule and I I'm sure
that's not the intention of it um I
think this is a a a bad way to get at a
problem that I think is real
um and that's really the only thing that
I haven't heard said all afternoon is
that you might have animal shelters
unable to place these types of dogs and
cats and rabbits um because of the way
the language is written and even if they
are excluded somehow we we have to give
them away for free I I see this being
something that shelters might start to
shy away from taking the animals in
because they don't want to get in
trouble they don't know what to do they
don't know how to deal with it and so we
might end up putting the burden back
onto the the person who just died and
well I guess they're dead they're no
burden but the family that has an animal
that they have to rehome that um now can
can't go to a typical animal shelter um
lots of other thoughts but I'll leave it
there representative coma thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question at this late hour um working at
Pope Memorial and bringing up the
shelter issue um brings to mind a
question that I've had do you think that
this could cause a um a lot of these
animals to be euthanized um because
there may be no place for them to
go I think that would be an extreme
solution but it's a fear that I have it
would never be a shelter's first
choice
um but it's it's something I'm afraid
Could Happen um I'm more worried that
the animals just will be turned away um
and in some cases maybe they do get
euthanized
because especially if um whoever decides
this decided that transferring ownership
equals selling even if there's no money
involved that that that I don't know um
but if we are unable to change the
ownership of the animal um even for free
then there would be nowhere for them to
go we couldn't send them
scary any other questions from the
committee no um I I have a question a
couple of questions actually
um
in in this bill it says cells an animal
that has a birth deformity that causes
suffering
um I mean such as there's such as braisy
or the intentional breeding with the
intent to sell two individual animals
with the same birth deformity that
um how how do in your matter of practice
do you do do you see many birth
deformities in dogs or cats I guess it
depends on who's defining birth
deformity and we've had lots of
discussion about um I see lots of
braches phalic dogs and cats that have
respiratory and muscular skeletal
problems um I think the other problem I
have with Bill is that there's no
clarity about when those
anatomic traits become
suffering um you you have the extremes
and at some point yes suffering happens
but who's
deciding when it becomes suffering and
when it's fine um so I yeah I I think a
lot of people don't recognize the
suffering that the animals have um I I
personally think we should be res doing
something to to make dogs have longer
noses than the extremes that a lot of
them do um but there's a lot of other
medical problems that are related to all
the the the breeding interbreeding that
we do to create pure Brits
um I don't know if legislation is the
way to fix it but I I think there is
suffering
um it might not be severe all the time
but there's a lot of dogs that are very
happy when I put a tube into their
throat to clean their teeth that's the
most oxygen their brain has had in their
whole life because I've given them an
actual
Airway um so does that um justify not
letting them exist I don't know I don't
know that that's for me to say and I I
feel like it might come to the
veterinarians to decide this is
suffering this isn't this is
anatomically too much this isn't and I
it's very gray I think that'd be very
hard
when when do
those when does the um the severity tend
to show itself more prevalently I mean
can you see that as a puppy can you see
that does it does it take a couple of
months or years to devel dep on the
condition
Breaky um as other people have said um
body weight and body condition has a lot
to do with it so a puppy might look fine
uh and then it grows up and it gets
spayed and it gets overweight and then
its breathing becomes worse so it really
depends on the
condition um if we're talking extremes I
think most people would agree like the
dog's passing out that's bad um it's the
other less severe cases where there'd be
a lot of disagreement even among experts
about where it's what what about birth
deformities like six-toed cats I mean
does do cats have suffering with having
six toes another Gray Zone yeah
generally no I don't think so but some
of those extra toes have this funky claw
in the middle that if you don't trim it
it grows around and embeds itself into
the
foot so that's a husbandry issue more
than a birth deformity
issue yes that's a good point that there
are lots of unintentional birth
deformities that can cause suffering
okay representative Penza and then
representative
Howard we might um I just want to I
thank you for your testimony and you've
stayed till the end and I think you're
the last and I I think your testimony I
wish it was heard by everyone else um I
I think you got to the point of what
most of us kind of feel here is do you
feel like that the way that this is
solved not through legislation but is
through you know it's is it through
breeders and vets and um in the Humane
Society working together to try to um to
get to a point where do you know what
I'm saying yeah I um I wasn't gonna say
this but I was recently on the um Animal
Welfare committee for the American
Association of feline practitioners it's
like the National Cat vet Association
and we just crafted a statement on
Breaky seil and cat breeding um and um
so there's a lot of discussion about
this um this position statement we
crafted does not include any legislative
bans or prohibitions it's more about
what you've described um changing breed
standards and breeding animals with the
priority being their health rather than
the consumer's desire for cuteness um or
whatever
um so yes I think that there's already a
lot of that discussion happening um and
I don't know how you would legislate it
and make it fair and and and have it be
actual
useful representative Howard thank you
madam chair um so I'm I you cast a
little confusion on on what a conclusion
that I had come to before so you said um
I don't know if this problem is worth
getting rid you know Banning the the
breed so so I guess just for
clarification for my for my sake is the
is the the breeds are these this type of
um of
anatomy absolutely prone toward this or
I mean I I you said that it has to do
with body weight and all that stuff I I
understand there's complications but but
um is is it I mean it's sort of you took
me back to square one when you said
that so your question is um is it really
the anatomy that's the problem or is
it in the case of Breaky short noses um
I think that's a big part of it um and
the the problems that those dogs and
cats have uh their nostrils are too
narrow their trachea is too small can't
really fix that um and then they have
some problems with their larynx and
their pal it um and to me
anatomically we've we've taken their
skull and bred it to be short and their
nose their facial bones to be short but
all the soft tissue kind of stays pretty
the same that's why their tongues stick
out so far when you look into their
throat there's folds of tissue and
there's just stuff in the way um so I
think there's a pretty clear Connection
in my mind that the anatomy
it's just making it hard for them to
move
air I think so I mean I I haven't looked
at all the studies and I can't speak to
that but um when I look into those
throats it's narrow it's like you can't
fit a normal siiz endot tral tube into
some of these throats you have to put a
smaller one in than you'd expect for the
size of the dog so I I think there's a
true um
yeah
yeah representative kto thank you madam
chair and thank you again um having
owned uh some of the breeds uh
listed and not having any issues at all
with
breathing and then having uh other
breeds great pair crosses uh that I have
bred
uh and what I have found in my
experience
and maybe you can attested it is that it
anatomically someone a dog may be more
prone to something you know like I
testified said earlier I had a dog that
was prone to HP topasia obviously uh the
box or the sharpi and the Rott Wier
which uh you're saying is prone to the
Boaz however I never experienced any of
that but U my great peer that I had no
issues with and plenty of litters that
never had an issue I ran to someone that
they had one of my pups that had
allergies the first one in like 30 dogs
right um however I think that
environmental issues as we discussed
earlier including how they're fed
because we're talking body weight and
things like that have a lot to do with a
lot of these issues um what what would
you say I agree
completely
if you have uh
Boaz and your overweight your Boaz will
be worse just like if you have sleep
apnea and your overweight you have worse
sleep lapa and if you lost the weight
you'd breathe
better thank you yeah any other
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you very much for coming today is
speak
of different animals there's a short
bear and a giant kangaroo they were all
naturally so it's not something we
invented for no reason okay thank
you
sure
I know thank you okay thank you want to
thank you all for hanging in there and
staying as long and I also want to thank
my committee for um for all your uh
attention and good questions afternoon
and uh I guess we'll see you tomorrow
morning I'm GNA I'm gonna I'm going to